MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING --
A HOUSEKEEPING ITEM THAT WE HAVE.
A DOCTOR JIM WOOD AS A
SUBSTITUTE FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ARAMBULA WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPERATING AS A SUB COMMITTEE DUE
TO A LACK OF QUORUM -- BUT
HAVING SAID THAT -- WILL MAKE
SURE THAT -- WE WILL ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE WE MOVE FORWARD SO --
MOVING IN FILE ORDER WE HAVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB
ONE NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON.
AND JUST FOR A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AT UP TO
TWO MINUTES FOR THIS BILL.
SUMMER CALDERON WELCOME PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB ONE NINETY NINE
THE CALIFORNIA ONLINE.
NOTARIZED ATION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN NOW.
I DON'T REMEMBER I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU GUYS KNOW THE LAST TIME YOU
HAD TO USE A NOTARY BUT I
REMEMBER THE LAST TIME I HAD TO
USE A NOTARY AND IT WAS JUST
LAST YEAR SO I DO NOT ONE
WITHOUT FOR OFFICE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE.
YOUR PAPERS NOTARIZED IN ORDER
TO FILE THAT YOU COULD DO THAT
AT THE COUNTY OR IF YOU CAN'T GO
MAKE IT DOWN THE COUNTY
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A NOTARY COME MEET UP.
AND WALK TO SIGN THE PAPER AND
AUTHORIZES WELL THAT WAS MY
SITUATION AND WHEN I DID THAT.
THE ONLY TIME I COULD DO IT THAT
MET UP WITH THE NET MIGHT.
THAT THE TIME WITH THE NOTARY
THAT I WAS GOING TO USE WAS WHEN
MY WIFE PICKED ME UP.
FROM THE AIRPORT AFTER FLYING
HOME AFTER SESSION -- SO THAT I
COULD GO WITH HER TO HER HAIR
APPOINTMENT.
SO THAT I CAN WATCH AT THAT TIME
OUR EIGHT MONTH OLD -- BECAUSE
SHE DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY WATCHER
AND I WAS COMING IN HER MOM
COULD HELP I AND SO WHILE MY
WIFE WAS GETTING HER HAIR DONE I
HAD TO THEN GO INTO A HOTEL THAT
WAS NEXT TO HER HAIR SALON.
MEET WITH THE NOTARY AND HAVE.
HER WATCH WE SIGNED THE PAPERS
AND RIGHTS PAPERS VERIFY THAT I
AM WHO I SAY I AM AND THAT WAS
MY LAST EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD.
WITH.
A NOTARY SO [inaudible]
BUT TECHNOLOGY AND THE INTERNET
HAVE SIMPLIFIED MOST.
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE CONSUMERS CAN NOW SAFELY
AND SECURELY APPLY FOR MORTGAGES
ONLINE PROVIDE DOCUMENTATION
THROUGH WEB PORTALS OF
SMARTPHONES.
AND CHECK THE STATUS OF THEIR
APPLICATION ALL OVER THE
INTERNET.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO NOTARIZED
DOCUMENTS CALIFORNIANS ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET IN PERSON WITH
A NOTARY OR INVITE A MOBILE
NOTARY INTO THEIR HOME WHICH CAN
BE TIME CONSUMING AND BURDENSOME.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
UPDATES THIS ANTIQUATED SYSTEM
BY AUTHORIZING REMOTE ONLINE
NOTARIZED ATION CALIFORNIA?
THIS MEASURE PERMITS WON'T PAN
ON MY NOTARY APPROVED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO NOTARIZED
A DOCUMENT WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO APPEARS BEFORE THE NOTARY BY
SECURE TO WEIGH IN OUR
INTERACTIVE VIDEO AND AUDIO AND
VIDEO COMMUNICATIONS THE BILL
DIRECTS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO DROP REGULATIONS. TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW CURRENTLY
SIXTEEN STATES HAVE ENACTED LAWS
NOTARIZED NATION CALIFORNIA NEED
TO KEEP UP WITH THIS TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY INNOVATION.
WHERE THE TECH CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR US
NOT TO BE ABLE?
TO DO THIS AND HOW THIS
IMPLEMENTED BE ABLE TO FIGURE
THIS OUT AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPLEMENT THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY IN A SAFE.
SECURE AND CONSUMER FRIENDLY WAY
ENSURE THE USE OF SO THE SAFE
NEW EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES ARE
NOT HINDERED SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE IN OF COURSE.
THE COMMITTEES -- TIME AND HELP
AS WELL AS WILL ALWAYS COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ANY
OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE ANY ISSUES --
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO FIGURE
OUT HERE WITH ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OUR BILL ANDERSON WAS A
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT THE NATIONAL NOTARY
ASSOCIATION AND PATTERSON SOLA.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM NOT LETTER SENT VICE
PRESIDENT.
AT THE NATIONAL NOTARY
ASSOCIATION.
THE INTERNET WHICH IS BASED IN
CHATSWORTH CALIFORNIA.
SEARCH CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SIX THOUSAND NOTARIES
PUBLIC.
WITH MEMBERSHIP INFORMATION
SERVICES TRAINING COURSES.
PONCE INSURANCE AND ORDER
SUPPLIES. FIFTEEN STATES HAVE
ENACTED ON WHY NOT A RECESSION
SO FAR INCLUDING FIVE DRESSED IN
THIS YEAR ALONE. TWENTY TWO
STATES HAVE INTRODUCED BILLS
JUST LIKE A. B. ONE NINETY NINE
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
REAL LIFE DEPLOYMENTS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT ON WHY NOT A
RECESSION PRESERVES THE
INTEGRITY OF THE NOTARIAL ACT.
AND CORPORATION PORTENT
SAFEGUARDS THAT MAKE ONLINE
NOTRE STATION SECURE.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES.
FIRST.
THE CUSTOMER MUST HAVE THEIR
IDENTITY FAT IT BY ANSWERING
CHALLENGE QUESTIONS.
THE ANSWERS TO WHICH ONLY THE
CUSTOMER BUT NOW [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
THE CUSTOMER THE AFTER ID
ANALYZED TO ENSURE ITS GENUINE
[inaudible]
THIRDLY.
AN AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING.
OF THE ONLINE OR CHARTER LACKED
MUST BE CAPPED ALLOWING ANYONE
TO VERIFY THE ONLINE ACT AFTER
THE FACT.
AND FOURTH.
THE ONLINE NOTARY MUST FIX THE
ONLINE NOTARIES WHAT TRYING
EXTRATORRENT SEE UP WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT WILL DISPLAY TAMPERING WITH
HER CHANGES TO ANY DOCUMENT
AFTER IT SON.
THAT'S THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALL
POINTED OUT AB ONE NINETY NINE
MAKES IT MORE CONVENIENT TO
ACCESS AND NO DOORS WHEREVER AND
WHENEVER YOU WANT.
THE END ENABLE WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND IN STAKEHOLDERS ON
ANY ISSUES THAT REMAIN. TO
ENSURE THAT THE ONLINE DOT ORG
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN PROTECTS
THE PUBLIC.
IN ALL WHO RELY UNDER TERREL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT SERVES THE NEEDS OF NOT
RESPUBLIKA WILL PERFORM ONLINE
BETTER SESSIONS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PAT IS ANGELA I'M
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS AB ONE ANY
NINE BECAUSE REMOTE ONLINE
NOTIFICATION WILL UPDATE AND
MAKE MORE CONVENIENT MORTGAGE
TRANSACTIONS FOR CONSUMERS FOR
NOTARIES AND FOR LENDERS WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THE NECESSARY
AUTHENTICATION AND SECURITY.
THE MORTGAGE INDUSTRY IS
SHIFTING FROM AN IN PERSON HEAVY
PAPER PROCESS TO MORE
STREAMLINED CONSUMER FRIENDLY
TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN PROCESS.
AND THE NEXT STEP IN DOING THAT
IS TO IMPROVE A CLOSINGS THROUGH
REMOTE REMOTE ONLINE ORDERS
ATION OR RON.
RON WOULD ALLOW CONSUMERS IN THE
NOTARY TO BE IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND STILL SAFELY SIGN
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY SO THE
PROCESS FOR MORTGAGES IS IS
BECOMING MORE TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO THE NOTRE IS
ATION A PART OF THE PROCESS IT'S
LIKE GOING BACK IN A TIME
MACHINE.
AT THAT POINT YOU'RE EITHER AS
ASSEMBLYMAN CALDERON MENTION
EITHER HEADING TO MEET IN ORDER
YOUR NOBODY'S COMING TO YOU
WHILE THE REST OF THE MORTGAGE
PROCESS IS KEPT UP WITH THE
TIMES THE CLOSING HAS NOT FOR
THIS REASON WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME FROM MIKE FROM NAME
AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ANNA BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING EMILY HAPPENS ON
BEHALF OF NOTARIZED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
NEARLY FOR JOHN WITH MAKE YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MY NAME IS TERRY
VANDERBUR CEO SAFE DOCKS AND
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN ON ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP.
TO THE TABLE HERE AND AGAIN WILL
ALLOW UP TO THREE MINUTES OF IN
TOTAL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLYMAN CAULDRON MY NAME
IS MATT MILLER I'M AN ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA NOTARY PUBLIC AND THE
ORGANIZER PROPOSED AB.
ONE NINETY NINE I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING INDEPENDENT
NOTARIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION ALL OVER OUR STATE
WE'RE NOT HERE TO STAND IN THE
WAY OF PROGRESS BUT WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN CONTRADICTS
THE CURRENT CODE.
WILL PUT NEW REASON THE PUBLIC A
LARGE DIRECTLY INTO HARM'S WAY.
TWO POINTS I WANTED TO POINT A
CONCERN I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY OUR DATA PRIVACY CONCERNS
AND LIABILITY ISSUES.
CURRENTLY INFORMATION COLLECTED
IN AN ETERNAL TRANSACTION IS A
WRITTEN PROCESS AND IS
MAINTAINED EXCLUSIVELY BY THE
NOTARY NEVER SHARE TO PUT ON THE
INTERNET AND SOUL.
THIS DATA IS KEPT BY THE
NUTRIENT TOLD RETIREMENT OR
DEATH UPON WHICH TIME TO
SURRENDER TO THE COUNTY CLERK
FOR RECORDING.
THE CORE A AS DESCRIBED IN
ARTICLE TWO SECTION EIGHT TWO
THREE ONE DOT SIX THIS BILL
STATE THAT AN ONLINE NOTARY
PUBLIC SO KEEP AN ELECTRONIC
JOURNAL AND RECORD EACH ONLINE
TO REACT PERFORMED INCLUDING
IDENTITY INFORMATION CITY CHORES
AND PHYSICAL LOCATION OF THE
PRINCIPLE.
ALSO THE PRINCIPAL MUST UPLOAD A
COPY OF EVERY DOCUMENT BEING
NOTARIZED TO THE ONLINE NOTARIES
PLATFORM.
HOWEVER THIS BILL CONTAINS NO
LANGUAGE THAT PROTECTS THE
PRINCIPLES ARE NOTARIES DATA
FROM BEING MINED SHARED OR SOLD
BY THE HANDFUL OF TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES HOSTING THE ONLINE
PLATFORMS REQUIRED BY THIS BILL.
NOR DOES THIS BILL ADDRESS DATA
BREACHES OUTAGES OR DATA LOSSES
THIS BILL ALSO DOES NOT DIRECTLY
LINK THE TIME ELECTRONIC CHECK
THE ACTUAL DATA MUST BE STORED.
REGARDS TO EXCESSIVE LIABILITY
ISSUES ACCORDING TO ARTICLE TWO
SECTION EIGHT TWO THREE ONE DOT
FIVE THIS BILL STATES THAT AN
ONLINE NEW REPUBLIC MAY
PERFORMER ON LATER IS SAFE FOR
PRINCIPLE LOCATED ANYWHERE ON
THE PLANET.
IF THE ONLINE ORDERING HAS NO
KNOWLEDGE THE NOTARY ACT IS
PROHIBITED IN THE JURISDICTION
IN WHICH THE PRINCIPLES LOOK AT
THE TIME OF THE MILITARIZATION.
SO AB ONE NINETY NINE IMPOSES AN
IMPOSSIBLE NUDITY UPON NOTARIES
TO CONFIRM THE LOCATION OF THE
REMOTE SIGNER AND ANOTHER
NOTARIAL LAWS OF ALL FIFTY
STATES AND A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
SOVEREIGN STATES ON THE GLOW.
IN THE STATE OF IOWA FOR EXAMPLE
THE LAW INCLUDES A PROVISION
THAT STATES NO RESERVATIONS
PERFORMED IN ANOTHER STATE WILL
ONLY BE RECOGNIZED IF THE SIGNER
IS PHYSICALLY LOCATED BEFORE
PHYSICALLY APPEARED BEFORE THE
NOTARY.
SO ULTIMATELY THIS BILL CREEK
LIABILITY ISSUES FOR NOTARIES
NEW RISING DOCUMENTS ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO ENSURE THE LOCATION OF
THE PRINCIPAL AND WHATNOT TERREL
EXPERT HEADED IN THE
JURISDICTION WHERE THE
PRINCIPALS PHYSICALLY LOCATED.
MEMBERS THESE ARE JUST A COUPLE
OF OUR MANY CONCERNS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO WHOM ALL
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA NO REPUBLICS ARE
ACCOUNTABLE WAS OPPOSED TO THIS --
SAME BILL IN THE LAST SESSION
FOR MULTIPLE CONCERNS OTHER THAN
OUR OWN.
DESPITE HAVING MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND THIS COMMITTEE THERE
HAVE BEEN NO AMENDMENTS TO DATE
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU TABLE
THIS BILL TODAY SO THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND NOTARIES.
CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
AUTHOR TO CRAFT A BETTER BILL
THAT PROTECTS DATA PRIVACY AND
ALIGNS WITH KERR NOTARIAL CODE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLYMAN CALDERON I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND ONE NOW
YOU'LL THE FLOOR SO THAT OTHER
OPPOSITION -- OTHER FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION TO MAKE THE VOICE OF
GREAT FIFTEEN SECONDS LEFT.
A MISTER LOGAN'S RUN KINGSTON I
REPRESENT THE ESCROW INSTITUTED
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE PRINCIPALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT ONE THING.
WHEN WE SEE AN IRREGULARITY IN A
NOTARIZED DOCUMENT?
WE WON'T KNOW -- THE ENTERED THE
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY.
BECAUSE IF IT WAS RECORD IF THE
AT THE ROOT A NOTARY WAS
RECORDED IN CONNECTICUT FOR
EXAMPLE NO DEA NO ENFORCEMENT
ARM WILL GO THERE -- WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH.
MISTER CALDERON -- WE HAVE MET
WITH HIM HIS STAFF WE RECOGNIZE
THE BILL SHOULD GO ON A
COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND ANY AMENDMENTS ARE REALLY
CRITICALLY NECESSARY AS BEEN
OUTLINED IN OUR THANK YOU LETTER
AND I KNOW I NEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DID YOU HAVE ANY SOME JUST
SUMMARY COM.
DID YOU HAVE A STATEMENT ON THE
CALIFORNIA NOTARY IT'LL TAKE
LESS THAN A MINUTE OKAY WOULD
YOU CAN YOU DO IT IN FIFTEEN
SECONDS.
PLEASE JUST FIFTEEN SECONDS ON
THE NOTARIAL ACT IS ALL ABOUT
FRAUD PREVENTION PERSONAL
APPEARANCES THE CORNERSTONE FOR
THE PREVENTION OF FRAUD DURING A
NOTARIAL ACT.
WHEN WE DO THAT THROUGH THE
FOLLOWING MEANS WE TOUCH THE
SIGNERS IDENTIFICATION AND
COMPARE THE IDEA TO THE PERSON
BEFORE US AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE LOOK AT AND TALK TO THE
PERSON TO ASSESS WILLINGNESS AND
DETERMINE MENTAL CAPACITY DURING
THE NOTARIAL ACT?
IF NEEDED WE ASK OTHERS TO LEAVE
THE ROOM TO DO THIS THIS CANNOT
BE RELIABLY ACCOMPLISHED
REMOTELY DEPICT VIDEO TECHNOLOGY
ISRAEL STEADILY ADVANCING AND OF
DEEP CONCERN.
SO THE TERMS REMOTE AND NOTRE IS
ATION ARE MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
BUT WE WANT TO BE FAIR WITH
EVERYONE'S TIME.
NOW IN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
HI MY NAME IS TERRY GILLETTE AND
I'M A FULL TIME PROFESSIONAL
NOTARY IN MARIN COUNTY I OPPOSE
THIS BILL IT IS AS AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN FOR MANY
REASONS.
BUT EVER MOST IS THE LACK OF
SECURITY FOR THE DOCUMENTS THAT
RUN THROUGH THE ONLINE PROVIDER.
THE NEXT TIME YOU ARE PERHAPS
ONE OF YOUR KIDS BUYS A
REFINANCE IS A HOME ALL THE
INFORMATION ON YOUR LOAN
APPLICATION WILL NOT BE SECURE.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THROUGH THE
PROCESS FOR THE SECURITY IT'S
NOT JUST YOUR BANK BALANCES ON
YOUR ACCOUNTS BUT ALSO YOUR
ACCOUNT NUMBERS IT'S NOT JUST A
CREDIT CARD BALANCES.
BUT YOUR CREDIT CARD NUMBERS --
IT'S NOT JUST YOUR HOUSE ADDRESS
IT'S ALL THE ADDRESSES FOR THE
PROPERTY THAT YOU OWN SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER MONTHLY INCOME
IT TO ADDRESS.
I RESPECTIVELY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM I AM A EVEN TOWARDS A
NOTARY PUBLIC AND SPECIFICALLY A
LOAN FINING AGENT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WRITTEN.
OF THE NOTARY PUBLIC IS AN OATH
TO FOLLOW THE LAWS AS WRITTEN
AND ACCEPTS CONSEQUENCES.
IF HE OR SHE FAILS IN THOSE
DUTIES -- THIS LOOK UP I AM A
NOTARY PUBLIC -- AN EXPERT LOAN
FINING AGENT AND I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO STREAMLINE THE
MORTGAGE INDUSTRY -- BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT IT'S THE NUMBER
THE NOTARY IS NOT THE BOTTLENECK
THE ACTUAL -- LAST PROCESS OF
POSING THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT
WHERE THE BOTTLE NECK IS.
SO THE BIT THE BILL AS WRITTEN I
OPPOSE SO THAT IT CAN BE RE
WRITTEN -- WITH THE HELP OF
ACTUAL NOTARIES DURING THE
CLOSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA WINTERS AND
I AM A NOTARY PUBLIC IN ANOTHER
WE FIND AN AGENT I UNDERSTAND
WITH THE BILL IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
BUT I HAVE.
DONE THIRTY TWO YEARS WITH STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I'M RETIRED NOW
BUT I WAS A CONTRACT MANAGER AND
I DID DO MULTI MILLION DOLLAR I.
T. CONTRACT SO I UNDERSTAND.
HOW IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO STAY UP ON
TECHNOLOGY HOWEVER I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE I FEEL THAT
IT'S NOT PROTECTED?
THE CUSTOMER THAT WE SERVE AND
ALSO FOR THE NOTABLY WHEN THE
NOTARY NOTARIZED WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PERSON IS WHO THEY
SAY THEY ARE EVEN IF WE USE THE
BLACK LIGHT AGAINST THE
FLASHLIGHT -- GETS THEIR ID CARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE WHO
THEY ARE WE ALSO TAKE CLASSES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE IDENTIFIED THE
PEOPLE PROPERLY WITHOUT THIS I
THINK IT'S A HUGE LIABILITY FOR
THE MOLD EVERYTHING YOU'LL START
HAVING NOTARIES DROP OUT.
THANK YOU VERY AND I THINK ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
YES PLEASE IF YOU COULD.
THE COMMISSION MY PHONE.
MY NAME IS FRANK ABOUT ECONOMIC
CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC AYE OPPOSED
THIS BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN
BECAUSE EVERY NO REPUBLIC WOULD
HAVE TO KNOW ALL.
THE NOTARY LAWS IN ALL FIFTY
STATES.
DO ALL ATTORNEYS IN EACH STATE.
OR ALL CPA'S IN EACH STATE.
NO ALL THE LAWS IN ALL FIFTY
STATES.
NO THEY DON'T.
SO WHY SHOULD WE BE REQUIRED.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER HAD --
Là AND I'M A NOTARY PUBLIC AND
ALONE CITING AGENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE
PRIMARY DUTIES OF A NOTARY IS TO
MEET WITH THE PERSON FACE TO
FACE AND ALSO TO SEE THEIR ID IN
PERSON.
AND THIS BILL WOULD TAKE AWAY
THAT POSSIBILITY I OPPOSE ONE
NINETY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIFTY MARK ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE OUT EXPEDIA WERE
A TWEENER WE JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE MEMBER SO MUCH FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK THE STATE.
OF HOLDERS AND WE WE HAD
CONCERNS LAST YEAR THAT WE
STATED IN A LETTER VOTE OUT OF
RESPECT FOR IT TO THE VERY
GENUINE EARNEST AND OF VISIONARY --
VIEW THAT THE AUTHOR HAS FOR THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WE HAVE NO
FORMAL POSITION AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible] SIX YES PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO LINE UP AN APPROPRIATE
FASHION IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE LINE UP SO THIS IS THE
FINAL PERSON IF I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY ELSE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M ANDREA AND I AM A NOTARY
PUBLIC AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT WOULD JUST MAKE IT
TOO EASY FOR PEOPLE TO TRY TO
MANIPULATE.
THE SYSTEM VIA.
BEING NOT FULLY VERIFIED IN
PERSON THAT'S IT THANKS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'LL GO TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A SAYS ONE MORE TIME ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE LINE UP.
NOW.
SEEN KNOWN WE HAVE A FINAL
PERSON SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION GO
AHEAD THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY
NAME IS SUZANNE I'M THE OWNER OF
FIELD WITH INTEGRITY.
I AM IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
AND IS AS IT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AS IT DOES NOT SUPPORT
THOSE OF US THAT DEPEND ON THIS
IS OUR PRIMARY SOURCE OF INCOME
TO HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY. TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT OUR CLIENTS AND
PROTECT THE PLOT PUBLIC UNDER
THE OATH THAT WE HAVE TAKEN.
AS NOTARIES PUBLIC IT DOES NOT
SUPPORT THAT THE TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT ARE REQUIRED.
ARE NOT IN REACH OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE AN IMPACT OUR ECONOMY
IN A NEGATIVE WAY SO AT THIS
TIME I DO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEY
GIVE TO EVERYONE WHO'S COME TO
THE STATE CAPITOL TO PROVIDE
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW I'M BRINGING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO THE BNP
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEM NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME WE CURRENTLY -- ARE NOT
ABLE TO DEVOTE TO THE LACK OF A
QUORUM -- BUT A SIMILAR COLOR DO
YOU WISH TO CLOSE YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO DRESS A
COUPLE THINGS --YOU KNOW WHEN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT -- AND BECOMES
EFFECTIVE JENNER FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND WITH THAT LAW
CALIFORNIA WILL LEAD THE NATION
IN SANDERS FOR STANDARDS FOR
DATA SECURITY THIS LANDMARK
LEGISLATION REQUIRES DATA TO BE
ENCRYPTED AND KEPT SAFE AND IN
THE EVENT.
OF A BREACH REQUIRES
NOTIFICATION AND VERY STRONG
REMEDIESTHIS BILL REQUIRES THE
NOTARY TO PERFORM THE ACT WITHIN
THEIR COMMISSIONING JURISDICTION
IN ACCORDANCE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS AND SUBJECT TO CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATION AND SUPERVISION.
MUCH AS THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO
IN THE TRADITIONAL PAPER NOTARY
ACT SO THERE IS NO ISSUE OF A
NOTARY TRYING TO PERFORM AN ACT
IN.
ANOTHER JURISDICTION AND FINALLY
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE JOURNAL
BE CAPPED UNDER SIMILAR
STANDARDS TO PAPER NOTARIES.
INCLUDING IT BE KEPT UNDER THE
EXCLUSIVE CONTROL OF AN AN
INDIVIDUAL NOTARY AND GIVEN TO A
COUNTY CLERK AT THE TERMINATION
OF THE COMMISSION.
HOWEVER THE PRACTICAL SECURITY
ASPECTS OF ONLINE PERFORMANCE
GOODNESS ACETATE HAVING A
SEPARATE JOURNAL FOR EACH
PLATFORM WHICH IS SOMETHING WE
WILL ALLOW THE NOTARY TO DECIDE
FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CHOICE.
NOBODY'S GONNA BE REQUIRED TO
USE AN ONLINE NOTARY IT'S UP TO
THE INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE CHANGE IS DIFFICULT EVERY
TIME WE TRY TO DO SOMETHING NEW
WE GET PUSHED BACK I UNDERSTAND
IT.
AS OPPOSITION FROM NOTARY TODAY
THERE SIXTEEN OTHER STATES ARE
CURRENTLY DO THIS NOT ONE
POSITION OF ANYBODY THAT CAME
FORWARD DID ANYBODY SAY FROM ANY
ONE OF THOSE SIXTEEN STATES OR
SOMETHING WRONG HAPPENS.
OR THAT SOMETHING BAD HAPPENED
SO WHY IS IT THAT IT CAN BE DONE
RIGHT SIXTEEN OTHER STATE BUT
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE TRY TO DO
THIS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE SO -- YOU KNOW.
WHEN I MET WITH THAT MISTER
VI<c.cyan> WE HAD A LOT OF</c>
CONVERSATIONS HIS HIS CONCERNS
WERE MORE FOCUSED ON THE COST
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WERE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIS OFFICE
ON?
HAVE A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP SO I'VE VERY
CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
TO GET TO IN.
A MINIMAL POSITION WITH HIM --
AND THEN ALSO WHEN IT COMES TO
NOT CARING ABOUT THE NOTARIES IN
THEIR BUSINESS AYE I ABSOLUTELY
DISAGREE -- THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS
AND GOING ONLINE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE FOR NEW BUSINESS NEW
ACCESS MAKING THIS MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO MORE PEOPLE WHICH
I THINK WILL BE GET MORE CLIENTS
AND SELL WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE NINETY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON --
SIMILARLY -- I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE ARTICULATED TO ADD TO OUR
COMMITTEE THE UTILIZATION OF
REMOTE -- NORMALIZATION AT AND
THE UTILITY OF NEWER TECHNOLOGY
THAT EXISTS TO ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE MUCH OF THE JOB
CREATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL TOO I'VE ALSO
STATED PUBLICLY THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION.
AS THE BILL A SHOULD CONTINUE
NOT AFFORD SO APPRECIATE THAT
THE PUBLIC ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AS
WELL TOO SO HAVING SAID THAT WE
ARE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW AND WILL TAKE UP THE
BILL ME AS HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE NOW MOVE ON THEN TO A FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL [inaudible]
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN AGAIN
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
MEMBER [inaudible]
GABRIEL AB. THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
I KNOW.
I HAVE A WITNESS I BELIEVE IS
HEREBY TASK.
NUMBER OKAY [inaudible]
IF THERE [inaudible] ONE YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE HE'S COME.
IT'S QUITE A CROWD OUT THERE YES
IS THERE IS QUITE A CROWD JUST
AS A AS A REMINDER WILL OUT UP
TO THREE MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY.
OF FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
COURSE THE AUTHORS FEEL FREE.
TO TAKE OUR LONG AS YOU WISH BUT
AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS AB.
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL SIMILAR
GABRIEL PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN A BILL THAT
WOULD MAKE.
MINOR CHANGES TO PRESCRIPTION
DRUG LABELING TO HELP AVOID
CONFUSION REDUCE ERRORS AND
IMPROVE PATIENT SAFETY.
THE GENESIS OF THIS BILL IS A
CONVERSATION I HAD WITH SOME
SENIORS IN MY DISTRICT TO
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THE
ENORMOUS COSTS OF ADVERSE DRUG
EVENTS.
CAUSED BY CONFUSION AROUND
PRESCRIPTION DRUG LABELING.
THE ISSUE RESONATED WITH ME
BECAUSE IT WAS CONSISTENT WITH
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY GRANDFATHER
SUFFERED A SCARY EPISODE WHEN HE
WAS TRAVELING IN CONFUSED TWO OF
HIS MEDICATIONS.
AS I LOOKED INTO THE ISSUE I WAS
STRUCK BY THE DATA WHICH
DEMONSTRATES THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM.
DUE TO MEDICATIONS WITH SIMILAR
NAMES ARE ESTIMATED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN COSTS EVERY YEAR.
IN FACT EACH YEAR ADVERSE DRUG
OFFENSE ACCOUNT FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND COST THE U.
S. HEALTHCARE SYSTEM FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN EASY WAY
TO PREVENT THOSE ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES BY ENCOURAGING
PHYSICIANS TO WHAT'S THE PURPOSE
OF A DRUG ON ITS PRESCRIPTION
LABEL WHICH HELPS REMIND
PATIENTS WHICH MEDICATION IS FOR
WHICH ELEMENT.
THE FIX IS A SIMPLE AS ADDING
TWO OR THREE WORDS FOR EXAMPLE
WRITING FOR ASTHMA OR FOR BLOOD
PRESSURE OR FOR BACK PAIN AT THE
END OF A LABEL.
THE OPTION IS ALREADY AVAILABLE
FOR PATIENTS THIS BILL MERELY
CHANGES THE CURRENT SYSTEM FROM
AN OPT IN TO AN OPT OUT.
THE BILL ALSO PRESERVES PATIENT
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENTIALITY
SINCE WHAT IF ANYTHING IS
PRINTED ON THE LABEL IS ENTIRELY
THE PATIENT'S DISCRETION.
THE PATIENT CAN DECIDE NOT TO
HAVE ANYTHING PRINTED ON THE
LABEL OR THE PHYSICIAN CAN
DESCRIBE THE PURPOSE OF THE
MEDICATION AT A HIGH LEVEL OF
GENERALITY SUCH AS FOR INFECTION
THAT WILL NOT DISCLOSE ANY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION.
I'M ALSO PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS FROM THE PHARMACIST AND
RETAILERS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH PHYSICIANS TO ADDRESS
THEIR IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT FOR SOME
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY SENIORS
THERE CAN BE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
FOR FAILING TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN TWO MEDICATIONS THAT
LOOK OR SOUND ALIKE.
ADDING A FEW WORDS ABOUT THE
PURPOSE OF A MEDICATION TO ITS
LABEL IS AN EASY WAY TO AVOID
CONFUSION REDUCE ERRORS AND
IMPROVE PATIENT SAFETY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TED TOP IN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE RETIREES.
STOPPING.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TED
TOP IN FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
RETIREE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS A BILL WE'VE SUPPORTED
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE --
A PRETTY WERE THE PURPOSE WE
WOULD SAY A SIMPLE DESCRIPTION
OF WHAT A JUDGE PURPOSES.
THAT WILL LIMIT.
DRUG ADVERSE FACTS AND EVENTS.
AND LEAD.
TO IMPROVED HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
DOT JUST RETIREES AND SENIORS
BUT ALL CALIFORNIANS.
MERGER AYE VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
YOU PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
STATE YOUR NAME.
IT WILL BE READY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAKING ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
THEME IS REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB THREE SEVEN AS IT RAISES
SERIOUS PRIVACY CONCERNS ADDS
EVEN MORE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
TO PHYSICIANS AND IS NOT
NECESSARY AS THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THE REASON FOR PRESCRIPTION
PRINTED.
ON THE PRESCRIPTION LABEL IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE TO PATIENTS AB
THREE TO SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE A
POSITION TO PUT THE REASON FOR
PRESCRIPTION ON THE LABEL OF
EVERY PRESCRIPTION WRITTEN FOR A
DRUG OR DEVICE.
WELL THE AUTHOR INTENDED
FLEXIBILITY.
BY USING THE TERM REASON FOR THE
PRESCRIPTION WE INTERPRET THAT
REASON TO BE THE DIAGNOSIS WHICH
THE DRUG IS BEING PRESCRIBED TO
TREAT.
SO UNDER THIS BILL EVERY
PATIENT'S DIAGNOSIS WHICH
REQUIRES TREATMENT.
WOULD BE PRINTED ON THE LABEL OF
ALL OF THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS
UNLESS THEY AFFIRMATIVELY OPTED
OUT.
THIS RAISES SERIOUS PRIVACY
CONCERNS AS A DIAGNOSIS.
OR REASON NECESSITATING
MEDICATION IS CONFIDENTIAL AND
SENSITIVE INFORMATION SHARED
BETWEEN A PATIENT AND THEIR
POSITION.
PATIENTS MAY VERY WELL NOT WANT
THEIR CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
SHARED WITH THEIR PHARMACIST
PHARMACY TECH.
OR ANYONE ELSE THAT MIGHT COME
ACROSS THEIR PRESCRIPTION LABEL.
THEY'RE ALSO IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES TO THIS PROVISION.
SUCH AS HOW MANY TIMES A PATIENT
WOULD HAVE TO OPT OUT IF THEY
DIDN'T WANT THEIR DIAGNOSIS ON
THE PRESCRIPTIONS.
WOULD BE ONCE AND COVER ALL
MEDICATIONS OR WHAT IT HOW WOULD
THEY HAVE TO OPT OUT FOR EACH
MEDICATION WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
A PATIENT SENT A MESSAGE THEIR
POSITION AND THE POSITION THEN
EAT PRESCRIBE MEDICATION.
WITHOUT THE PATIENT HAVING A
CHANCE TO OPT OUT.
THESE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES ALSO
RAISE THE SECOND MAJOR CONCERN
WHICH IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN.
WE FREQUENTLY DISCUSSED THAT THE
HIGH COST OF HEALTHCARE AND
POSITION ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AS A DRIVER OF THESE COSTS THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE PHYSICIAN TO
ASK EVERY PATIENT FOR EVERY
PRESCRIPTION.
IF THEY WANTED THEIR MEDICATION
LABELED WHETHER DIAGNOSIS OR
REASON FOR NEEDING THE
MEDICATION.
THE SIX CRITICAL TIME AWAY FROM
THE ALREADY TIME CRINGED
APPOINTMENTS FINALLY THESE
PRIVACY CONCERNS ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS COULD BE ALLEVIATE
ALLEVIATED.
BY SIMPLY UTILIZING THE
MECHANISM IN PLACE CURRENTLY
WHICH ALLOWS FOR A PATIENT TO
REQUEST THE SPECIFIC REASON OR
DIAGNOSIS INFORMATION TO BE
PRINTED ON THEIR PRESCRIPTION
LABEL.
AND THEN REQUIRES THAT THE
INFORMATION TRANSMITTED TO THE
PHARMACY IS PLACED ON THE LABEL
OF MAKING MAJOR TROUBLE FOR
WOMAN SO WE CAN A SUBSEQUENT
PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOW.
HERE BROKE.
BLOOM GEN [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY EGGMAN FONG.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN.
PROBLEMATIC [inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
WHAT?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE BELIEVE THE CURRENT MECHANISM
FOR LABELING CAN BE AS ACTIVE
AND SUFFICIENT IF UTILIZED BY
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION PRINTED ON THE LABEL
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE BRAG
REMAIN OPPOSED AB THREE TO SEVEN
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SNYDER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESSED -- A FEW OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE DID REYES WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT AND HOPE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR -- AS WE CONTINUE TO
RAISE A FEW MORE CONCERNS LIKE
TO ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE -- BRACE BY MAKING HER
WITH CMA THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION -- WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT PATIENT
PRIVACY ABOUT CONDITION ON THE
LABEL THAT MIGHT BE AN OFF LABEL
USE OF THAT DRUG AND THE ABILITY
FOR US TO FOR OUR PHARMACISTS
ABOUT ACTUALLY BE ABLE -- TO
PLACE THE CONDITION ON THE LABEL
AND HAVE THAT LABEL BE ABLE TO
BE READ I'M NOT KNOWING EXACTLY
HOW LONG THAT CONDITION SHOULD
BE.
I'M MORE CONCERNED THAT PATIENTS
MAY NOT WANT TO HAVE THE
CONDITION ON THEIR LABEL AND
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT LIABILITY
ISSUES IF AGAIN IF IT'S AN OFF
LABEL USE -- THE CONDITION IS
NOT.
DIRECTLY AFFILIATED WITH WHAT
THE FDA APPROVES FOR THAT DRUG --
AGAIN WE DO APPRECIATE THE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN --
THEY THEY ACTUALLY DRESSED AND
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE CONCERNS
FOR OUR PHARMACIES WAS IF OF
POSITION DOES NOT HAVE THE
CONDITION ON THE PRESCRIPTION AS
IT COMES TO THE PHARMACY WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PHARMACY HAVING TO FOLLOW UP.
AND WITH EVERY PHYSICIAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT CONDITION WAS ON
THE LABEL SO WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THAT.
WAS ADDRESSED IN THE AMENDMENTS
HI MY HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR OF IT AND DO
HAVE CONTINUED CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO LINE UP HERE
AT THE MICROPHONE THEY CAN THIS
IS WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR
AB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO LINE ABOUT THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU WISH.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AGAIN
NAME IN FILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION JUST REAL BRIEFLY.
IF A MENTAL HEALTH OR A
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSIS IS PUT ON
A LABEL AND AND IT'S DONE SO
INADVERTENTLY.
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS DO A
COMPANY MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE
CERTAIN THAT THAT -- INDIVIDUAL
WHAT WE CHOOSE TO OPT OUT -- A
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD WITH BI
POLAR.
AND HAVING THAT FACT DISCLOSED --
COULD HAVE THAT CONSEQUENCE
FOLLOW THEM THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFE AND THAT IS A VERY SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCE AN OUTCOME.
TO SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NOW FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
MISSED THE MISTER GABRIEL TO
BEGINNING OUR THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YEAR YOU'RE ACCEPTING
US I YES SIR.
BUT I'D.
I THINK YOU'RE TACKLING A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS REALLY MAKE
THE BILL A LOT BETTER.
IN MY OPINION IT IT SHIFTS ME --
TO POSITION OF OPPOSED TO
POSITION OF YOU KNOW TRYING TO
GET TO SUPPORT -- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD THOUGH REGARDS
THE LANGUAGE FOR OPT OUT AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CONFUSION
ABOUT THAT AND I'VE HAD PEOPLE
ASK ME.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN THAT -- YOU
HAVE TO OPT OUT -- EVERY SINGLE
TIME IN OTHER WORDS IS THE
PHYSICIAN REQUIRED TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH THE PATIENT FOR
EVERY PRESCRIPTION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT TO OPT OUT OR
IS THE PAY IS IF THE PATIENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO SAY HEY I'D
LIKE TO OPT OUT.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S IN AN ACTUAL
QUESTION AND AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT IN THIS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT -- I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
DISCUSS WITH CMA YESTERDAY
UNFORTUNATELY TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO TO MEET IN PERSON AND UNTIL
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON -- WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO ANY KIND OF
CONVERSATION TO IT REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN SUPPORT
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS NOT.
TO PLACE AN ADDITIONAL MYSTERY
TO BIRDS ON PHYSICIANS WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE OVERWORKED IT'S TWO
IN APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES
TRIGGER THIRTY SECOND
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE PATIENT
AND THEIR PHYSICIAN WHICH THEY
CAN.
THE THE THE PATIENT CAN MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY THEY WANT TO OPT OUT IF
THERE'S SOME KIND OF BLANKET OPT
OUT FORM THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
THE PATIENT THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE BE OPEN TO PUTTING
IN AS WELL -- AND AND WE'VE
EXPRESSED OUR ARE ARE VERY
SINCERE DESIRE TO WORK WITH
THOSE WERE IN OPPOSITION TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MINIMIZE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS WHILE
STILL PRESERVING FOR THE PATIENT.
THE RIGHT TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO HAVE TWO OR
THREE WORDS PRINTED ON THE LABEL
THAT MIGHT HELP REMIND THEM WHY
THEY'RE TAKING A CERTAIN
PRESCRIPTION.
GREAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I THINK THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS WOULD MAKE THE BILL
BETTER AND I THINK AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD HERE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO CONTINUE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE I
THINK YOU NEED SOME MORE
LANGUAGE IN THERE TO TO REALLY
CLEARLY DEFINED WHAT IT MEANS TO
OPT OUT -- TO TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THAT THAT'S NOT OBLIGATION
IN A POSITION IT'S AN OPTION FOR
THE PATIENT -- AND ALSO MAYBE TO
LOOK AT OTHER SECTIONS OF CODE
FOR LANGUAGE THAT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT ONCE YOU'VE OPTED OUT YOU
CAN OPT THAT OPT OUT CAN BE --
APPLY PERMANENTLY RATHER THAN
HAVING TO OPT OUT OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATIONS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS ALL
THOSE IS AGAINST THE ILLUSTRATE
THE GREAT WORK OF A COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT ACKNOWLEDGEMENT WOULD THEN
GO TO DOCTOR EGGMAN FALL BY
DOCTOR WOULD.
I THINK YOU -- I THINK YOU BRING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S I'VE WORKED A LOT
WITH THE SENIOR LEGISLATURE ALSO.
AND I KNOW THEY HAVE A LOT OF
PASSION ABOUT A LOT OF ISSUES --
I'VE I'VE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT ABOUT THIS BILL
AND NOT WELL WELL I THINK IT
PROBABLY NEEDS TO GO FORWARD I'M
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY -- AS SOMEONE WHOSE WORK
WITH PEOPLE WHO FOR WHOM
CONFIDENTIALITY IS NO POURTANT
ISSUE I YOU KNOW PEOPLE GO WHEN
PEOPLE'S BATHROOMS THEY OPEN
THEIR CABINETS I DON'T KNOW IF
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE BEING TREATED.
FOR DEPRESSION OR RECTAL
DYSFUNCTION OR VENEREAL DISEASE
OR WHATEVER THE PLETHORA OF THAT
PEOPLE MIGHT BE BEING TREATED --
FOR SO I GUESS I JUST SEE IT
MORE A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMMONSENSE RATHER THAN.
AN AUTOMATIC OPT IN WHY NOT JUST
HAVE THE PHYSICIAN ASK THE
PATIENT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPT IN.
VERSES AND A MANDATORY OPTION SO
THAT'S TO ME THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMMONSENSE OR IF IT'S IF
IT'S FOR SENIORS THAT WE'RE
TARGETING THEN MAKE IT.
ALTHOUGH I'M I'M APPROACHING AT
SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER -- VERSUS
BEING A BLANKET FOR FOR
EVERYBODY.
SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS AND AND
I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS MOVE FORWARD AND WORKING ON
THIS BILL.
I THINK IT'S AN INTERESTING.
ISSUE BUT I THINK JUST ASKING
PEOPLE IF THEY WOULD LIKE THAT
INFORMATION ON THEIR LABEL MIGHT
BE AN EASIER WAY THAN JUST
MANDATING IT BE ON THERE FOR
EVERYBODY.
YEAH I AND I I JUST TO TO BE
CLEAR IF I MIGHT RESPOND ESTHER
CHAIR THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW OUR
ART THE ATTENTION OF THE BILLS
TO TRIGGER A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN AND I I THINK THAT'S
PART OF WHAT'S REQUIRED AS A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
PHYSICIAN AND THE PATIENT -- AND
WE'VE PURPOSELY CRAFTER THE
LANGUAGE DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
DIAGNOSIS RIGHT IT REQUIRES THE
PURPOSE AND LEAVES UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF BOTH ULTIMATELY
THE PATIENT BUT ALSO THE FISH
PHYSICIAN.
THE LEVEL OF GENERALITY WHICH TO
DESCRIBE IT SO YOU CAN IMAGINE A
SITUATION WHERE THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT SENSITIVE OR THE
KIND OF DIAGNOSIS THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT WANT TO KEEP CONFIDENTIAL
IT'S A 100% IN THE PATIENT'S.
DISCRETION AT THAT POINT TO ASK
THE PHYSICIAN OR TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION POSITIONS A NOW.
I PREFER THAT THAT NOT BE ON THE
LABEL AND THERE'S NOTHING HERE
THAT WOULD PREVENT THE PHYSICIAN
FROM SAYING TO THE PATIENT MIGHT
I SUGGEST THAT WE NOT PUT THIS
ON THE LABEL RIGHT SO IT'S I I
THINK IT'S IT JUST LEAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR VERY COMMONSENSE
APPROACH.
IT ALSO IT THE THE LEVEL OF
GENERALITY WHICH SOMETHING IS
DESCRIBED IS IS UP TO THE IS UP
TO THE PHYSICIAN AND THE PATIENT
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT RIGHT
SO.
RATHER THAN SAYING YOU KNOW FOR
VENEREAL DISEASE YOU COULD CHECK
FOR INFECTION OR SOMETHING AT A
AT A AT A HIGH LEVEL OF
GENERALITY THAT WON'T DISCLOSE
ANY CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
STILL PROVIDE A TRIGGER OR
REMINDER IF THE PATIENT WANTS.
ONE WITHOUT RECALL WITHOUT
DISCLOSING ANY CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION AND YOUR FINAL POINT
ABOUT AGE YES WE HAVE HEARD A
LOT OF CONCERNS FROM SENIORS
ABOUT THIS.
BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM FOLKS
ABOUT THE CARE GIVERS OF SENIORS
WHO MAY WANT TO BE REMINDED IF
THERE'S A LOT OF MEDICATIONS.
AND ALSO FOR PARENTS RIGHT TO
HAVE CHILDREN WHO MAY HAVE -- A
VARIETY OF AILMENTS MAYBE ON A
LOT OF DRUGS IN THEIR
MINISTERING ALONE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TRUCKS TO THEIR
CHILDREN TO HAVE A REMINDER ON
THE BOTTLE -- OF WHICH DRUGS FOR
WHICH EMMET CAN HELP THEM TO
AVOID CONFUSION BECAUSE THE
NAMES OF THESE MEDICATIONS ARE
SO LONG SO COMPLICATED ARE OFTEN
COMMON NAMES THAT ARE EASY TO
CONFUSE AND SO THIS IS JUST
ABOUT ADDING TWO OR THREE WORDS.
AT THE PATIENT SELECTION TO HELP
AVOID THAT CONFUSION WHICH ARE
WE SEEN AS A WRIT IS A REAL
ISSUE IT'S IT'S ASSAULTING IN
DEATH IT'S COSTING OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE THINK THERE'S AN EASY FIX
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WHAT.
YES I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
GABER FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- IT KIND OF MAKES ME
REFLECT ON WHEN I WAS
PRESCRIBING ON A REGULAR BASIS I
WOULD ROUTINELY.
THIS IS BEING PRESCRIBED FOR
PAIN THIS IS BEING PRESCRIBED --
FOR INFECTION I DID THAT --
MAKES ME NOW WONDER IF I'M IN
VIOLATION OF SOMETHING -- BUT
BUT BECAUSE I KNEW THAT MY
PATIENTS DIDN'T ALWAYS KNOW.
WHAT THE THIS PARTICULAR
MEDICATIONS WERE?
FOR NOW AS I CARE FOR MY MY
MOTHER WHO HAS -- SOME COGNITIVE
ISSUES -- AND IN SHARING THAT
CARE WITH TWO BROTHERS WHO HAVE
NO EXPERIENCE IN HEALTH CARE --
AND SHE'S TAKING A MYRIAD OF
MEDIC MEDICATIONS AND BEING
ASSISTED BY AN ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY THERE -- TRYING TO KEEP
TRACK OF WHAT THE DIFFERENT
MEDICATIONS ARE FOR IS A
CHALLENGE WHEN YOU DEAL WITH
MULTIPLE PARTIES SO I I
COMPLETELY APPRECIATE THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS.
BUT I ALSO AND GET CONCERNED
THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL
CONFUSION AND THAT A PATIENT A
PERSON MIGHT ACTUALLY END UP
TAKING THE WRONG MEDICATIONS ARE
TOO MUCH OF THE WRONG
MEDICATIONS -- AND SO -- YOU
KNOW I CAN'T CONTROL SOMEONE
GOING INTO SOMEBODY'S -- HOUSE
AND AND DO THAT AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T EXPECT THE PEOPLE ARE
WALKING AROUND WITH ALL THESE
MEDICATIONS AROUND THEIR NECKS
AND I CAN NECKLACE.
SO -- SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING -- WASN'T EVEN
AWARE THAT -- THERE WAS -- AN
OPT IN POTENTIAL OUT THERE
BECAUSE I JUST ROUTINELY WE CAN
PRESCRIBE A LOT OF THAT IS
REALLY DIDN'T PRESCRIBE THINGS
IN DENTISTRY.
THAT WOULD RAISE A LOT OF
EYEBROWS SO THEY'RE A COUPLE
MEDICATIONS THAT PEOPLE MIGHT
WONDER ABOUT.
BUT BUT SO I APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I HOPE THAT
AS I I KNOW YOU COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS.
AND PRIVACY CONCERNS ARE AN
ISSUE BUT I ALSO THINK -- SAFETY
IS AN ISSUE -- FOR PEOPLE AND
AND AND SOME SENIORS ARE HAVING
SCHOOL HAVING HAVING CHALLENGES
SO I APPRECIATE PRETTY WEIRD
WHICH WERE YOU TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS GAME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AS A MEMBER
GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THE MISTER REAL THANK YOU
FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
I REALLY APPRECIATED COMING
FORWARD AND I UNDERSTAND THE
SITE ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE -- SOME KIND OF
IDENTIFIER ON THE LABEL TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE TAKING THE
RIGHT PRESCRIPTIONS -- AT THE
SAME TIME I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS -- SPECIALLY
THAT MY COLLEAGUE DR EGGMAN
BROUGHT UP AS WELL I SURE THOSE
CONCERNS A SHE ARTICULATED A LOT
MORE A LOT BETTER THAN I COULD --
SO I FIND MYSELF IN A A PLACE
TODAY WHERE I'D PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO VOTE ON THIS BUT I DO
LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING IT.
AS IT MOVES FORWARD WITH THE
CONTINUED WORK THAT YOU HAVE
COMMITTED TO DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
THE ONE THING THAT -- DID CATCH
ME REAL QUICK WAS THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT JUST INITIATING A
FIFTEEN SECOND CONVERSATION WITH
THE WITH THE DOCTOR AND THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
COULD NOT ALREADY BE DONE NOW
WITH THE FIFTEEN SECONDS --
CONVERSATION WHERE THE DOCTOR
ADDRESSES THE PATIENT SAYS WOULD
YOU LIKE ME -- TO PUT THIS ON
THE PRESCRIPTION LABEL -- OR IS
IT IN YOUR ESTIMATION ABSOLUTE
NECESSARY THAT WE SWITCH OF FROM
AN OPT IN TO AN OPT OUT.
I I'M NOT SURE -- BY THE WAY THE
CONVERSATION TO TAKE PLACE
[inaudible]
SO.
YEAH I THINK I THINK THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I APPRECIATED --
AND AND ALSO THE VERY CIRCUIT
SINCE YOUR PRIVACY CONCERNS AND
UNDERSTAND THOSE -- THE THE THE
THINKING ABOUT GOING FROM -- IN
OPT INTO AN OPT OUT IS WHEN IT'S
AN OPTION IT REQUIRES THE
PATIENT TO KNOW THAT SO YOU
THERE BEEN SOME SUGGESTION THAT
RATHER DURING THIS BILL WE
SHOULD DO AN EDUCATION CAMPAIGN
BUT AT THAT POINT WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO EDUCATE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE.
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC RIGHT THAT
THEY HAVE WHO HAVE LESS
INTERACTION WITH THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM MAY ONLY GET A COUPLE OF
PRESCRIPTIONS A YEAR -- VERSUS
GOING TO THE FOLKS WHO ARE
PRESCRIBING MEDICATION
PRESUMABLY EVERY DAY -- HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH THEM AND
JUST PUTTING ON THEM -- THE ONUS
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
THEIR PATIENTS AND YOU KNOW I'VE
EXPRESSED TO TO SEE A MAN TO
OTHERS -- WILLINGNESS -- TO
STRUCTURE THE IMPLEMENTATION IN
A WAY THAT WOULD BE FEASIBLE TO
PERHAPS HAVE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION GIVE THEM TIME TO
TO TRAIN AND WORK WITH PHYSICIAN
SO THAT THEY'RE AWARE OF THIS
REQUIREMENT.
AND PHASE IT IN IT IN A WAY THAT
WOULD BE -- THE MOST AMENABLE
FOR THAT SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF YOU
KNOW WHAT DO WE DO WE NEED TO WE
EDUCATE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
OPT IN OR DO WE ASK FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR PRESERVE.
WITH THEIR PATIENTS ABOUT THIS
AND WE JUST THOUGHT IT WAS A
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT TO TO TO
HAVE THE PHYSICIAN INITIATE THE
CONVERSE AYE.
AYE AYE WHAT A GREAT RESPONSE
AND SITTING RIGHT BESIDE DR WITH
HERE AND HAVING HIM SAY I WASN'T
EVEN AWARE THAT THERE WAS AN OPT
IN WAS -- INTERESTING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK THE OFFER BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT YOU AND I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
THIS BILL I KNOW THAT THEIR THIS
IS SOMETHING.
THAT YOUR HEART IS INVOLVED IN --
AND I KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY INDICATED -- THEIR
CONCERNS YOU WORK CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO I'M TRYING
TO GET EVERYONE THERE I WILL --
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION -- AND
LOOK FOR TO THIS BILL COMING ON
THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER APRIL DO YOU WISH
TO CLOSE -- APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE BEFORE TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS WANT TO
THANK THE THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR ACTUAL WORK AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ALSO
WANT TO ECHO THOSE COMMENTS WITH
RESPECT -- TO US THE AUTHOR IN
TRYINGTO WORK WITH A MANY
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AND NOT
ONLY TO THE PRESENT BUT IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL TOO SO.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND SECOND BY ASSEMBLY. ONE
FOR ONE TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I KNOW I BRO.
WE'RE NOT VOTING BLOOM.
CHEN [inaudible]
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DELANO EGGMAN.
IT MAY NOT VOTING FONG.
FONG NOW GIPSON R. GIPSON AYE
GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON OFFERING [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA?
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
WHAT WHAT I?
THE VOTE IS A SIXTY TWO WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS GABRIEL.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS AB FOR
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS AREA.
AGAIN.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT AND FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES IN.
SUPPORT UP TO THREE MINUTES
SOMERS THERE PLEASE FEEL FREE
PERCENT WHATEVER READY GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO START BY FIRST OF
ALL THINKING THE STAFF FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY WITH MY
OFFICE.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
THANK YOU AB FOR FIFTY IT WILL
ALLOW LICENSED OPTOMETRIST TO
BRING VISION SERVICES AND
TESTING TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONFINED TO THEIR HOMES.
AND WITH THAT.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE A
SHARE MURPHY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY.
GOOD MORNING ALL THINK YOU CHAIR
AND NOT MEMBERS FOR HEARING A
BILL TODAY THANK YOU AND MISS
AND SEVEN MILITARY AND FOR
AUTHORING INTO OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AN OPTOMETRIST AND OPTICIAN
COMMITTEES.
WHO HELPED US WITH TRAFFIC
NISPEL?
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN FOLKS WHO ARE
HOMEBOUND AND AN AGING
POPULATION WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BRING A TREATMENT TO THEM AS WE
HAVEN'T HAD ADVANCE ADVANCEMENTS.
IN TECHNOLOGY IN THE ABILITY TO
DO MORE REMOTE OR MOBILE CARE OF
WE SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANOTHER PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN -- TO ESTABLISH THAT
RELATIONSHIP AND KEEP FOLKS
WITHIN -- THE THE TREATMENT
WITHIN -- TREATMENT CIRCLES AND
AND GOT DOCTOR COMMUNICATIONS.
WE ARE.
OUR BECAUSE YOU'RE CRITICAL IS
IDENTIFIED NEEDED CLARIFICATION
OUR INTENT IS TO CREATE A
PRACTICE MODALITY IN PROVISIONS
TO ENSURE SAFETY AND
TRANSPARENCY THAT MODALITY AWAY
FROM TRADITIONAL MEDICAL OFFICER
CARE FACILITY.
IN DROPPING THE BILL.
SINCE I'VE BEEN AN INTENSELY
APPLY TO EXISTING PRACTICE
MODALITIES THAT WOULD DECREASE
ACCESS TO CARE IN I CARE IN
NURSING HOMES IN RESIDENTIAL
CARE WE'RE WORKING WITH LET'S
COUNCIL OF COURSE THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO SEPARATE THE PRISONS
FOR THOSE MODALITIES -- WERE
ALSO OF COURSE -- COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE LIABILITY OF
HOMEBOUND SENIORS TO FRAUDULENT
SOLICITATIONS AND SCAMS WE
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THE CLEAREST
POSSIBLE STATUTORY CHANGES TO
PROTECT SENIORS WILL PROBABLY
ALLOWING CONSUMERS ACCESS TO
CARE OPTIONS.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HEARING A STATE ASK YOUR ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS HAS THE
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OUT THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM KERN MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
A SIMILAR IS THERE AND YOU WISH
TO CLOSE.
I LOVE THE OPTIONS THAT'LL
MANAGEMENT OF THIS.
IS FANTASTIC.
IF YOU COULD ONLY SPEAK A LITTLE
FASTER MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A BOOK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS HAVE
BEEN IN MOTION A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECURE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FOR FOR FOUR FIFTY EIGHT A
DEVICE ADMITTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI SO I BROKE.
RELY BLOOM CHEN CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY MEDINA?
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE.
TING.
WHAT WHAT I [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE BILL AS A ELEVEN BOTH THE
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WE NOW MOVE INTO FILE ORDER
WHICH IS FILE AND A NUMBER.
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
BY DOCTOR WOULD.
AGAIN THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
[inaudible] EIGHT NINETY OUR
DOCTOR WOULD FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN I'M ASSUMING THAT WE ARE
STILL WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE. TO JOIN US SINCE -- IT
LOOKS QUITE BUSY OUT THERE DOING
A LONELY UP HERE YEAH.
SO -- I AGAIN WE'RE JUST GOING
TO CALL UP INDIVIDUALS -- THIS
IS NOW FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
EIGHT NINETY FOUR WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AFTER THREE MINUTES AND
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION UP TO
THREE MINUTES AS WELL BUT AT
DOCTOR LOOKS LIKE PEOPLE ARE
SOME TO FILE AND SO.
BILL PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR IN HIS STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR EFFORTS WORKING
WITH ME.
AND THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
TO REACH A CONCEPTUAL CREAM AND
ON THE BILL'S FRAMEWORK AND
AMENDMENTS.
AS SUCH WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
IT IS A ONE THANK BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
NURSE PRACTITIONERS THE
COMPROMISE IS BOTH GROUPS WERE
WILLING TO MAKE TO HELP US LAND
ON THE AGREED UPON FRAMEWORK WE
HAVE TODAY.
I KNOW IT WASN'T EASY FOR EITHER
PARTY.
I INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE WAS
PROMPTED BY A GROWING
REALIZATION THAT MANY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES I HAVE SUPPORTED TO
HELP INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS.
WAS JUST NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
WE CANNOT FIND ENOUGH RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS FOR LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMS TO MEET THE HEALTHCARE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
URBAN AREAS.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND A HALF ON
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION WORKFORCE COMMISSION
WORKING WITH STATEWIDE LEADERS
IN THE AREAS OF HEALTH LABOR
GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
ME CALIFORNIA'S WORKED OF COURSE
NEEDS. FOR THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS.
ALLOWING.
THERE'S PRACTITIONERS FULL SCOPE
AUTHORITY WAS ONE THAT REPORTS
TOP RECOMMENDATIONS THE BILL FOR
BEFORE YOU HAS THREE KEY
COMPONENTS FIRST ARE THE
PATHWAYS TO PRACTICING
UNSUPERVISED.
THE NURSE PRACTITIONER CAN
EITHER WORK AS A PART OF AN
INTEGRATED TEAM WHAT THEY WANT
TO PRACTICE OUTSIDE THOSE
SETTINGS THERE IS A REQUIREMENT
FOR A THREE YEAR TRANSITION TO
PRACTICE.
WHICH ONE BALL COMPENSATE MONEY
WILLS AND AN EXAM.
SECOND IS A REGULATORY STRUCTURE
INCLUDING A NEWLY CREATED BOARD
OF ADVANCED PRACTICE REGISTERED
NURSING IT TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION THE NEED FOR
PHYSICIAN INPUT AND INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
MAINTAINING A SINGLE STANDARD OF
CARE.
THIRD IS AN APPROACH THAT
PRESERVES THE CORPORATE BAN ON
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
SO THE PRACTICE IN PEACE WILL BE
TREATED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
PHYSICIANS WHILE ALSO PRESERVING
THE ABILITY OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO REMAIN
EMPLOYEES.
THEY CHOOSE BUT WITH DIFFERENT
RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES THAN THOSE
REPORTED AUTONOMOUS.
AND NURSE PRACTITIONERS ON ON A
HOSPITAL MEDICAL STAFF.
I BELIEVE THIS RISK FRAMEWORK
RIGHT REPRESENTS A BALANCE
BETWEEN GREATER AUTONOMY AND A
CAUTIOUS APPROACH TO SERVE AS
JURORS ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE AND MENTORSHIP PRIOR
TO ALLOWING AND THEN P.. TO WORK
OUTSIDE AN INTEGRATED SETTING WE
STILL HAVE ISSUES TO ADDRESS
INCLUDING HOW TO TRANSITION INTO
THE NEW PRACTICE ENVIRONMENT WAS
EXISTING MPS WHO HAVE BEEN MANY
YEARS OF PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE.
AS WELL SOME PRACTICAL ISSUES
INVOLVING THE TRANSITION TO A
NEW REGULATORY BOARD.
AND CONTENT I COMMITTED TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES AND AGAIN I WISH
TO THANK ALL INVOLVED FOR THEIR
PATIENTS AND THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS PROPOSAL.
WITH ME TODAY'S ADRIN SHELTON
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
HER SUBJECT MATTER SUSAN CHAPMAN.
WE CAN.
BUILD ON FIVE MINUTES OF FOR
WHEN THIS IS INTO A TALLY FOR
SUPPORT AND THEN UP TO FIVE
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION SO PLEASE
FEEL FREE PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHERRY MEMBERS
ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB EIGHT NINETY
TODAY.
THE SUMMER INSTITUTE IS COMING
OUT THIS ISSUE FROM AN ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PERSPECTIVE.
WE KNOW FROM RECENT STUDIES THAT
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA ADULTS
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS ARE NOT
RECEIVING TREATMENT.
AS WELL AS TWO THIRDS OF
ADOLESCENTS WITH SERIOUS
DEPRESSIVE CONDITIONS ARE ALSO
NOT RECEIVING TREATMENT.
WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH OF
OUR WORK FORCE ARE HEALTH
WORKFORCE IN THE RIGHT PLACES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR GROWING.
AGING AND INCREASINGLY DIVERSE
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
THAT'S WHAT HAS BROUGHT US TO
THIS ISSUE TODAY AND WHY WE ARE
SUPPORTING AB.
EIGHT NINETY I AM VERY PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE SUSAN CHAPMAN WHO
IS A PROFESSOR AT THE UCSF
SCHOOL OF NURSING AT A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT ON THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OFTHE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN
CHAPMAN AND I AM A PROFESSOR
UCSF IN THE SCHOOL OF NURSING
AND I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT NINETY I TRAINED AS A
PSYCH NURSE MANY YEARS AGO AND
WORKED IN THE FIELD FOR ABOUT
EIGHT YEARS BEFORE RETURNING TO
ACADEMIC WORK.
I'M NOW ON THE FACULTY AT UCSF
AND I TEACH HEALTH POLICY TO
NURSES.
I'M HERE TO TALK BUT I ALSO DO
WORK FORCE RESEARCHING OF DONE
THAT FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS.
I'M HERE TO TALK TO ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT PSYCH MENTAL HEALTH
AND PEACE ARE TO ADDRESSING OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK FORCE
CRISIS.
AS ADRIAN MENTIONED WE HAVE A
CRISIS US 17% OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE OF MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
ONLY ABOUT ONE IN.
TWENTY ARE ARE A BIT AND ONLY
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF TWO THIRDS
ARE NOT GETTING THE SERVICES
THEY NEED.
I'VE SPENT ABOUT FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS IN THE FIELD.
DOING RESEARCH -- INTERVIEWING.
PRACTITIONERS NURSES
PSYCHIATRISTS WHO ARE LOOKING
WHO ARE WORKING IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH FIELD.
WE CONDUCTED RESEARCH AND SIX
STATES WITH DIFFERENT SCOPES OF
PRACTICE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE LOOKED AT
FIVE COUNTIES.
IN OF I'LL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT
OUR FINDINGS ON THAT -- RELATED
TO SCOPE OF PRACTICE SUPERVISION
WAS REPORTED AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN BY MANY OF
OUR INTERVIEW IS.
FINDING A SUPERVISOR.
CHANGING A SUPERVISOR ONE ONE OR
THE OTHER LEFT THE PRACTICE.
SCHEDULING MEETINGS COULD
COMPETE WITH PATIENT CARE TIME.
IT'S ALSO COSTLY SUPERVISION IS
COSTLY TO THE ORGANIZATION
WHETHER IT'S A COST IN PAIN THE
PSYCHIATRISTS TO DO THE
SUPERVISION -- IN EXTRA SALARY
YOU'RE TAKING MONEY AWAY FROM
PATIENT CARE TAKING MONEY AWAY
FROM PATIENT CARE BASICALLY.
IT'S CAN BE COSTLY TO INDIVIDUAL
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WITH OUT OF
POCKET COSTS.
IN SOME STATES WE FOUND THAT
THAT NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE
PAYING UP TO THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OUT OF THEIR POCKET FOR
SUPERVISION EXPENSE.
YOU JUST SPEAK UP LOUDLY INTO
THE MIKE PLEASE SURE THANK YOU
SORRY.
IS THAT BETTER SORRY OKAY --
MORE IMPORTANTLY IN THE FIELD.
WE GOT A SENSE OF OF HOW THIS
WORKS MORE COLLABORATIVELY.
WE DIDN'T SEE AN ADVERSARIAL
PRACTICE ENVIRONMENT WE DIDN'T
SEE HIGHER ARKY.
WE SAW EVERYBODY WORKING
TOGETHER TO SHARE THE GOALS OF
PATIENT CARE AND ACCESS TO CARE.
AND RESPECT FOR EACH OTHER'S
EXPERTISE.
WE FOUND THE PRACTITIONERS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSULT WITH EACH OTHER A
DIFFICULT CASES CHALLENGING
CASES SOMETHING THAT WASN'T IN
THEIR EXPERTISE.
BUT THAT WAS BETWEEN NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PSYCHIATRISTS.
CONSULTATION IS GOOD
CONSULTATION IS HELPFUL
PARTICULARLY FOR NEW
PRACTITIONERS.
MANDATED SUPERVISION IS NOT THE
WAY TO APPROACH THAT
CONSULTATION.
SOME OF OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS REPORTED ALSO THAT IN
SOME COUNTIES THEY COULDN'T
RECRUIT PSYCHIATRISTS SO
THEREFORE THEY COULDN'T RECRUIT
IN PEACE.
IF YOU CAN'T RECORD A
PSYCHIATRIST YOU CAN'T RECRUIT
AN EMPTY.
IN THE PRACTICE AREA.
LACK OF IN PEACE CAN ALSO.
ADVERSELY IMPACT RURAL AREAS.
AS WE TRY TO ADDRESS THE WORLD
HEALTH WORK FORCE.
THE SUPERVISION ISSUE COMES UP
IF WE CAN FIND A PSYCHIATRIST TO
SUPERVISE IN A RURAL AREA WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO TRAIN THE THE
END PIECE THERE IT IT REALLY ARE
IS IS TO TAKE PEOPLE FROM THE
RURAL AREA.
AND GROW YOUR OWN THIRTY SECONDS
LEFT OKAY -- SO IN SUMMARY I
JUST WANTED TO SAY WE NEED
PSYCHIATRISTS AND WE NEED MENTAL
HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE BURDEN OF
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND THE
COST OF SUPERVISION.
AN INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CHRIS TWO WEEKS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WOULD
LIKE TO THINK.
OUR DOCTOR WOULD FOR ALL HIS
HARD WORK IN THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK BRINGING
US TO THIS PLACE TODAY.
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU DOES
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF
COMPROMISES THAT WE HAVE AGREED --
TO WE BELIEVE IT DOES STILL MOVE
NURSE PRACTITIONER PRACTICE
FORWARD AND WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE --
ACCESS TO CARE IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND WE
ARE WE WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW EDITION A WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE DO
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND
LINE UP THIS IS THE TIME FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY TO
LINE UP A PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
VALERIE LAKEY MAYORS MEMORIAL
HOSPITAL DISTRICT.
AND CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL IN
RURAL NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
ALSO FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
HI MARIA SPERBER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE TAKING A HARD
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS BUT ARE
GENERALLY SUPPORT IT.
MORE IN HIGGINS REPRESENTING AT
THEM IN SUPPORT.
MAP BROAD FOR THE ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT -- MICROBES AND ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
PATH DOCTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
RECRUITERS ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KELLY MAC MILLAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NURSE AND ASSESSES US.
IN SUPPORT REPRESENTING TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED NURSING ASSISTANT
STATE.
JEFF TO THE NURSE PRACTITIONER
IN RURAL NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE CURRENTLY LIMITED BY THE
LEAD THE CURRENT PRACTICE TO BE
ABLE TO OPEN CLINICS AND SERVE
THAT POPULATION SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT.
CHARLOTTE GOAL THAT MORE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AS
PRACTITIONERS SANTA BARBARA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
MENDOZA WITH US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
DR LIANA MESSA -- FROM SEIU
SEVEN TO ONE AND WORKING FOR A
ON PUBLIC SYSTEM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND FULL AND TOTAL
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR DEBORAH JOHNSON I AM OF
WITH UCS HALF A PROFESSOR -- FOR
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND THIS
BILL WOULD REALLY HELP US TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH EQUIPPING OUR
OUR STUDENTS AND TRAINING THEM.
GOOD MORNING CATHERINE RADIUS
NURSE PRACTITIONER FOR TWELVE
YEARS AT ALL OF YOU MEDICAL
CENTER I'M HERE AS AN ADVOCATE
FOR MY COMMUNITY -- WHICH IS LA
COUNTY THE UNDERSERVED.
DIVERSE -- IN VERY COMPLICATED
PATIENT POPULATION THIS WILL
HELP -- WITH WITH WHEN THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE LIFTED THIS
WILL HELP WITH REGARDS TO SEEING
OUR PATIENTS IN A TIMELY
EFFICIENT MANNER INSTEAD OF
WAITING FOR A LONG TIME TO GET
THE PROPER DIAGNOSIS THANK YOU.
YOU SEE A TIAS WORKERS
ESSENTIALS COUNTY DHS HARBOR
UCLA MEDICAL CENTER FOR TEN
YEARS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE IT JUST
LIKE CONFERENCE.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE READ THIS
WHAT THE CALIFORNIAPHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION IF --
AND PEAS ARE GRANTED THE
AUTHORITY TO DISPENSE WE JUST
WANT TO INSURE THAT THEY'RE HELD
TO THE SAME STANDARDS AS OTHER
PRESCRIBERS BUT WITH THAT WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M IN A WHILE THE
HEART WELL WITH A OR P.
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS A BIG
PRIORITY FOR A A RP WE WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND AGAIN
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M RON ARE DONE I
WE DO MEDICAL HOSPITAL VISITS
AND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US TO
REACH MORE PEOPLE ESPECIALLY IN
THE FAR OUT OF REACH AREAS THANK
YOU.
PAM FAIR REPRESENTING SEIU LOCAL
SEVEN TWO ONE WE REPRESENT EIGHT
THOUSAND NURSES.
SANTA BARBARA VENTURA LA RIVER
SIDE AND SEVERED AGAIN COUNTIES
AND WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FUN CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES -- TO
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR NOW LIKE
TO CALL UP.
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT NINETY THE KILEY MAKE SOME
ROOM.
HERE AT THE TABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AGAIN FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION UP TO FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAKING ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF
AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF WILL WORK TO SEE A MADE TO
DEVELOP FRAMEWORK THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FRAMEWORK WE
LAID OUT IN OUR LETTER.
HOWEVER MAJOR AND SUBSTANTIAL
SUBSTANTIVE DETAILS ARE YET TO
COME IN DISCUSSION.
THIS IS THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE AND THE FIRST HOUSE
AND WE WANTED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS A FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION TO
CONTINUE.
COMMITTEE AMENDS ACHIEVE THAT
BUT BY NO MEANS IS THE BILL A
FINISHED PRODUCT THERE STILL ARE
SIGNIFICANT AREAS IN WHICH WE
DIFFER FROM THE AUTHOR AND
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL THAT
IMPACT PATIENT SAFETY.
SUCH AS THE GRANDFATHERING IN OF
KERR NURSE PRACTITIONERS THE
COMPETENCY TEST REQUIREMENT.
AND LANGUAGE THAT NEEDS TO BE
INCLUDED TO ENSURE LAY
INDIVIDUALS AREN'T INTERFERING
WITH THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE THINK THAT THE
CORPORATE BAR SIMPLY IN THE CUT.
THINK OF THE COVER BAR SIMPLY IN
THE CONTEXT OF EMPLOYMENT.
IF THERE'S A WHOLE SET OF RULES
TO ENSURE PRACTITIONERS AREN'T
INTERFERED WITH IN TERMS OF
THEIR CLINICAL JUDGMENT.
AS A NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT
ENSURES THIS REMOVAL OF
SUPERVISION.
WILL ADDRESS ACCESS TO CARE WE
PASSED A LOTS OF DATA THAT
SHOWCASES THE FACT THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS DON'T MOVE TO
RURAL AREAS WHEN GRANTED
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE AND NOTHING
IN THE BILL ENSURES THAT THEY
WILL DO THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE COMFORTABLE CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION BUT ASK THE
MEMBERS RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
CHANGE THEIR VOTE ON THE FLOOR
OF THIS IS YET TO BE AS THIS IS
YET TO BE FULLY COOKED
LEGISLATION WITHOUT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED BUT LOOK
FOR ITS ON GOING DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU TERM LOW AN ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DOCTOR YURI AND I MADE DOUBLE
BOARD CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND IN THE
UNIVERSITY SETTING.
AFTER HEARING ABOUT THIS BILL I
CANCELED MY CLINIC TODAY AND
FLEW IN LAST NIGHT TO BE HERE.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF PHYSICIANS
FOR PATIENT PROTECTION A
GRASSROOTS GROUP OF TEN THOUSAND
PHYSICIANS ADVOCATING FOR
PHYSICIAN LIKE CARE.
AND TRANSPARENCY AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS.
I WANT TO EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION
AB EIGHT NINETY AS IT STANDS.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT I HAVE A DEEP RESPECT FOR
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AS THEY ARE
INTEGRAL MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTHCARETEAM.
THIS IS NOT A TURF WAR.
MY MOTHER WAS A GRADUATE OF THE
FIRST NURSE PRACTITIONER CLASS
AT UC DAVIS AT A I UNDERSTAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THEIR ROLE IN
HEALTH CARE.
HOWEVER I ALONG WITH MOST
PHYSICIANS IN THIS STATE ARE
OPPOSED INDEPENDENT PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE BY ADVANCED PRACTICE
NURSES WHO HAVE 3% OF THE TOTAL
TRAINING OF A BOARD CERTIFIED
PHYSICIAN. TO BE CLEAR NURSE
PRACTITIONER TRAINING IS NOT
EQUIVALENT TO PHYSICIAN TRAINING
IT IS AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
TRAINING BASE IN NURSING CARE
INSTEAD OF MEDICAL CARE. TO
BELIEVE THAT ADVANCED PRACTICE
PROVIDERS ARE OR CAN BECOME
EQUIVALENT TO BOARD CERTIFIED
PHYSICIANS IS NOT ONLY INCORRECT
IT'S DANGEROUS.
IT'S ANALOGOUS TO A DENTAL
HYGIENISTS PRACTICING
INDEPENDENT DENTISTRY OR
PARALEGALS PRACTICING LAW.
I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO ATTEMPT TO FILL THE
VOID OF A PERCEIVED PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGES SPECIAL IN RURAL AREAS.
MY MOM IS A FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONER IN A REAL HEALTH
CARE CLINIC IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FOR FORTY YEARS.
AND CARED FOR THE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE AT GREATEST RISK.
HOWEVER RECENT STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT IN STATES WHERE AND
P. INDEPENDENCE THAT
INDEPENDENCE IS LEGAL.
A SMALL PERCENTAGE ARE IN RULES
SETTINGS AND THE RATS PRACTICE
IN URBAN AND SUBURBAN SETTINGS
AND MOST PRACTICE SPECIALTY CARE
INSTEAD OF PRIMARY CARE OR
PSYCHIATRIC PSYCHIATRY.
THIS CLOSELY MIRRORS THE
PRACTICE DISTRIBUTION OF
PHYSICIANS AND DOESN'T REALLY
ALLEVIATE.
ANY SHORTAGES IN CARE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS
BILL FAILS TO MANDATE THAT ANY
NURSE PRACTITIONERS WHO CHOOSE
TO PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY SHOULD
ONLY DO SO WITHIN RURAL AREAS.
I WENT IN THE FIELD THE PRIMARY
CARE ONLY.
WITHOUT THIS STIPULATION THE
CORE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
LEFT UNADDRESSED.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
TRAINING AND OVERSIGHT OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IS NOT ADEQUATE
FOR INDEPENDENT PRACTICE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THE REALITY IS THAT YOU CANNOT
LEGISLATE EDUCATION.
NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE NOT
EDUCATED IN THE ART OF MEDICINE.
NOR DO THEY UNDERGO RIGOROUS
TESTING TO VALIDATE THEIR
COMPETENCY.
THE SIMPLE TRUTH IS THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE A PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE.
WE HAVE A LEGISLATIVE BOTTLENECK.
EVERY YEAR EIGHT THOUSAND
MEDICAL STILL SCHOOL GRADUATE
PHYSICIANS DON'T MATCH AND A
RESIDENCY POSITIONS BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
MAINTAINED ITS FUNDING CAP OF
MEDICARE FUNDED RESIDENCY
POSITION SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN DESPITE
HAVING FOUR YEARS OF MEDICAL
SCHOOL FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE
HOURS OF HANDS ON CLINICAL
PRACTICE.
THE NURSE PRACTITIONERS FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS OF SHADOWING THESE
ON MATCH POSITIONS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY.
INSTEAD OF SPENDING LARGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY INCREASING
NURSE PRACTITIONER TRAINING AND
CREATING A NEW REGULATORY BOARD
FOR THEM.
PERHAPS WE SHOULD FIND MORE
RESIDENCY POSITIONS AND
INCENTIVIZE PHYSICIANS TO STAY
WITHIN UNDERSERVED AREAS TEN
SECONDS LEFT THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND RULE
SETTING BUT THIS BILL AS IT
STANDS IS NOT THE ANSWER.
I BELIEVE THAT THE ANSWER WILL
INVOLVE SOME PERMUTATION OF AN
INCREASE IN PHYSICIAN RESIDENCY
POSITIONS AND INCENTIVES FOR
BOTH PHYSICIANS AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. TO PRACTICE
WITHIN RULES SETTINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FLYING ALL THE
WAY UP HERE TO PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY WHEN NOW CALL UP
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT NINETY PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME TO THE MICROPHONE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY AGAIN THIS IS NOW A
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS RANDALL
HAGER WITH A CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE LESS AMENDED ON THIS
BILL.
PRIOR TO THE AMENDMENTS WERE
STUDYING THEM -- I THINK WE
WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OUR
COMMENTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CMA.
ON THIS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING THE AUTHOR AND ON THOSE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN MOVE
THE BILL IF YOUR LINE UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE -- WITH
CONCERNS WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE POSITION I'M
DOUG CHIP PETA.
WITH THE UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS WE'RE
KIND OF A UNIQUE ENTITY IN THAT
WE REPRESENT GOVERNMENT
POSITIONS BUT DONNELLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
AUTHOR SO I WANT -- TO AVOID
GETTING INTO ANY TECHNICAL
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO THE
BILL I WOULD JUST SAY THIS THAT
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
HAS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
PUBLIC SECTOR POSITIONS.
WE'VE DEALT WITH THIS BILL OVER
THE YEARS SO CHAIRMAN HERNANDEZ
OF BROUGHT IT FORWARD FROM THE
SENATE A COUPLE TIMES BEEN THREE
OR COMMITTEE.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
SPIRITED DISCUSSION WITH A
DOCTOR WOULD.
AND HOPEFULLY RESOLVING SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU BUT AT
THIS POINT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS BUT WE'RE NOT NOT
POSITION THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DR NEAL CONNOR I'M
A PSYCHIATRIST OVER NAPA STATE
HOSPITAL AND I ALSO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR GRAY SAYING
I'M A CO CHAIR DEPARTMENT OF
MEDICINE ABOUT NAPA STATE
HOSPITAL.
AND I TO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
BILL.
EIGHT NINETY C. NOTATIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THE QUESTIONS NOW FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST OFF FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THIS
IS MORE IN THE WAY OF COMMA
DOCTOR WOULD FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOCUSING.
THIS LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION ON
WHAT I THINK IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST.
ISSUES FACING OUR STATE AND THAT
IS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
WE TALKED BEFORE AND LIKE YOU I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT'S
PRETTY RURAL.
AND I'M TELLING YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS SINCE I'VE BEEN
IN OFFICE IT.
IT IS TREMENDOUSLY CHALLENGING
TO GET QUALIFIED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO MOVE TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND INCREASE ACCESS
TO CARE -- SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH THE GOALS OF YOUR
BILL.
I HINK I'VE MET WITH ALL SIDES
ON THIS ISSUE I THINK EVERYBODY
MAKES REALLY.
HONESTLY GREAT POINTS AND AND IS
OPERATING GOOD FAITH -- I THINK
THIS THIS COULD REPRESENT A
POSITIVE MOVE FORWARD OUT RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A FEW ISSUES WITH
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE THING THAT
I'M STILL TRYING TO GET
COMFORTABLE WITH -- AWAY OFF THE
BILL TODAY -- AND I LOOK FOR TO
SING OUT OF ALSO IN THE PROCESS
BUT I THINK THERE.
I'D LIKE TO BROADEN THE
DISCUSSION TO AT A LATER TIME TO
YOU KNOW HOW COOPER ABOUT
TELEMEDICINE.
HOW CAN WE GET -- LOAN REPAYMENT
FOR DOCTORS IF THEY GO TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES HOW CAN WE DO OTHER
CREATIVE OUTSIDE THE BOX THINGS.
THAT GET MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
TO MOVE TO THESE UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND I THINK -- SO AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANKS FOR YOUR
FOCUS ON THIS THANKS FOR
DILIGENT WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE COMMUNITY GROUPS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THE
BILL OF ALSO IN THE PROCESS SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GIBSON FOLLOWED BY DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR ONE BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I KNOW HE AND I
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS
AS WELL AS I'VE HAD WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSITION.
I AM.
VERY CONFIDENT THAT DOCTOR WOODS
WILL TAKE EVERYTHING
CONSIDERATION WITH THE OP IT
REGARDING OPPOSITION THEIR
CONCERNS TO TRY TO GET TO A
BALANCE.
OF ONE THINK THE DOCTOR FOR
PROVIDING HER TESTIMONY MAKERS
SACRIFICE ON TO FLY HERE IN
REGISTERING YOUR CONCERNS --
WITH THE OP I'M WITH THE
PARTICULAR BILL -- BUT I AM I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT I'M MORE
CONFIDENT WITH THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK AND FIND A
BALANCE.
THAT THIS BALANCE CAN GO BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE IN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ANY KIND OF REFERENCE
RESERVATIONS WILL IN FACT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD.
AND SO I HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE IN
HARD AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO TRY
TO FIND A STRIKE THAT BALANCE IS
SO OBVIOUS SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD I I AM A PROUD CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL AND I HAVE THE I
THINK MAYBE SITTING IN THIS VERY
ROOM -- IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
IS THE FIRST TIME I HEARD IT AND
I HAVE CONTINUED TO BE.
A SUPPORTER -- AS FAR AS
EXPANDING ACCESS WE KNOW THAT
OTHER STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY
HAVE DUFFEL LICENSURE FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS POLITICAL TO
PRACTICE.
AND I THEN I ALSO THINK IT'S
IT'S RATHER INSULTING -- TO TO
COMPAREA NURSE PRACTITIONER TO
A DENTAL HYGIENIST -- I THINK
WE'RE TALKING APPLES AND ORANGES
AND THEN AGAIN WE KNOW THAT THIS
WORKS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.
WE KNOW AND NOT JUST IN RURAL
AREAS BUT IN URBAN AREAS WITH A
LOT OF THE HIGH DEGREE OF
POVERTY A HIGH DEGREE OF NEED --
THAT THERE IS A SEVERE PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE.
THIS WORKS OTHER PLACES THERE'S
NO -- THERE'S NO REASON IT CAN'T
WORK HERE.
AND I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AS IT GOES THROUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SUMMARY
DALY FALL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA.
I DO THINK THE AUTHOR AS SOMEONE
WHO.
HIS DISTRICTS SOMEWHAT MIRRORS
MINE AS FAR AS WATER BECOMES
VERY RULE -- I JUST WANT TO
SHARE A YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS
SOME THERE IS SOME -- OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE TAKEN A LOT OF AMENDMENTS.
TO YOU KNOW GET THE THE HOURS UP
AND GET THE THE TIME SPENT THERE
AND AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A
VERY REAL DISTRICT WE'VE TRIED
ALL THOSE THINGS TO GROW YOUR
OWN -- TRY TO GET PEOPLE TO OUR
REAL DISTRICTS AND IT'S IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT I'M GONNA SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY -- BUT I DO WANT
TO SHARE OF THAT -- AND I KNOW
THAT TO OUR RELATIONSHIP AND AND
ARE DISTRICTS HAVE SOME THIS
IMAGE THERE ARE A LOT OF DOC'S
WHO NEED RESIDENCY THAT'S A FACT.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE MEDICARE SYSTEM AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY.
FOR OUR RULE COMMUNITIES TO GET
LOAN REPAYMENT ON THEIR LOANS SO
THAT THEY WILL ACTUALLY GO OUT
AND SERVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
HOPEFULLY -- WE CAN GET THE
ACCESS TO CARE THAT WE NEED --
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THOSE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES -- TO GET THE
THE CERTIFIED DOCS OUT IN OUR
AREAS I HAPPEN TO HAVE A COUSIN
WHO IS A MEDICAL DOCTOR SIR
THIRTY YEARS IN MY COMMUNITY I
ACTUALLY WENT TO HIM AND SPOKE
WITH ABOUT THIS.
AND HE SAYS ABSOLUTELY AND OUR
PASTOR WHO'S BEEN -- PRACTICING
FOR SOMETIME -- SHOULD THIS THIS
BILL WOULD WORK FOR THAT -- FOR
ACCESS FOR THEM BUT SOMEBODY IN
THE YOU KNOW FIVE HUNDRED OUR
RANGE -- YES SOME SKEPTICISM
WITH WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT
TRYING TO JUST THOSE ISSUES SO I
APPRECIATE THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
WHEN IT THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD --
WE'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT
WHEN IT -- RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE DIFFERENTLY ON THE FLOOR --
IF CONCERNS ARE ARE NOT --
ADDRESSED.
I REPRESENT A CENTRAL.
INLAND CALIFORNIA.
OF RIVERSIDE AND SHARE THE
CONCERN ABOUT NOT ENOUGH
RESIDENCIES I RECENTLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE AT THE UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
MATCH DAY.
AND WATCHING THEM OPEN AND WITH
EXACT EXCITEMENT THEIR ENVELOPES
TO SEE WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO
BE DOING THEIR RESIDENCY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THOSE --
YOU SEE OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL
DOCTORS NOW ARE HAVING TO GO OUT
OF STATE. TO DO THE RESIDENCY
YOU KNOW THEY THEY PROMISED TO
COME BACK AND I HOPE THEY DO
BECAUSE THAT'S THE THAT WAS THE
INTENTION OF THE UC OUR SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE BUT WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO DO MORE -- TO IN IN THAT
REGARD -- SO I'LL BE SUBORDINATE
TODAY AND HOPE THAT THE DIALOGUE
CONTINUES AND THAT WE CAN.
RESOLVE SOME OF THE UNMET
[inaudible]
ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AYE SIR BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHART AND
DOCTOR WHAT I THINK EVERYTHING'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP THE CONCERNS OF
MEMBERS ONE THING THAT HASN'T
BEEN BROUGHT UP THAT I WANT.
TO BOB REYES AS YOU CONTINUE
YOUR WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION IS
THAT WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF OTHER
ENTITIES THE MIDWIVES AND
ATHLETIC TRAINERS THAT I'VE
WANTED.
NEW BOARDS -- THIS IS A NEW
BOARD AND I'M JUST FEARFUL THAT
THIS MAY OPEN THE GATE. TO OTHER --
MEDICAL PROVIDERS AND HAVE THEM
COME BACK IN.
AND SO JUST BE MINDFUL OF THAT
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED -- OTHER -- GROUPS
COME IN AND WANTED -- BOARD --
REPRESENTATION -- SO.
JUST WANNA MAKE THAT COMMENT WE
SHOULD MAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND SOME
MY COMMENTS VITAMIN TOUCHED ON
DOCTOR EGGMAN AGAIN TOUCHED ON
SOMETHING THAT I ALSO WANT TO
BRING AND HIGHLIGHT WE TALK
ABOUT THE RULE AREAS BEING
SERVICED.
HOWEVER THERE ARE URBAN AREAS
THAT WE FIND THAT ARE COMPLETELY
UNDERSERVED.
AND LACK OF HEALTH ACCESS --
NAMELY ONE IN RICHMOND WHERE
DOCTORS HOSPITAL WAS CLOSED.
AND THAT LEFT THE RESIDENCE OF
THAT CITY AND THAT ENTIRE AREA
WITHOUT ACCESS TO TO HEALTH SO I
THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
ADDRESSES THAT -- DOCTOR WOULD
DO YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IS IMPRESSIVE
YOU'D BE COMMENDED FOR THAT AS
WELL.
I'D ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS OF
RESIDENCY AND BOTH FOR DOCTORS
AS WELL AS A NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND THE AMOUNT THAT THEY HAVE
NOW VERSUS WHAT I BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE A BIT MORE ADEQUATE IF
THEY'RE GOING TO DO INDEPENDENT
WORK AS WELL SO -- LOOK FOR TO
SEE IN THIS BILL IS A PROGRESSES
FORWARD AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NOTE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME DOCTOR WHAT DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE I DO AND I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR AYE I WILL
MAKE ONE COMMENT -- WITH REGARDS
THE OPPOSITION AND THAT -- I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS SHORTAGE
OF PHYSICIANS IS A PERCEIVED
STORAGE I BELIEVE IT IS
ABSOLUTELY REAL -- WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF FORTY SEVEN WE WILL
HAVE BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE A
SHORTAGE OF FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
BY TWENTY THIRTY WILL BE TEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS IN THIS DAY.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE REAL SHORTAGE --
SO I THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT I JUST WANNA SAY --
ONCE AGAIN THAT I COMMIT TO ALL
OF YOU THAT I WILL CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS REGARDLESS OF HOW
YOU ABOUT TODAY.
I CAN TELL CONTINUE TO
ACCOMMODATE REQUESTED A
REASONABLE -- AND NOT INTENDED
TO UNDERMINE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL -- SASS TODAY THAT YOU VOTE
BASED ON THE POLICY AND I HOPE
THAT YOU AGREE WITH ME ON THE
POLICY AND THAT'S ABOUT I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WHICH
I WOULD LIKE TO AGAIN THANK ALL
PARTIES THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS PROCESS.
I SPECIALLY WANT TO THANK OUR
DILIGENT COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
HELPING TO FACILITATE AND COME
UP WITH LANGUAGE THAT IS
CONDUCIVE.
TO THIS CONVERSATION IN FACT I
CAN SMELL THE RED BULL LOSING
FROM THEIR SWEAT.
HI TO ME BECAUSE OF THE HOURS OF
WORK AND YOU CAN SEE THAT VIA
THE EMAILS AT FIVE O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING -- BEFORE GETTING IT
ONE HOUR'S SLEEP BECAUSE A WE
VERY MUCH CARE ABOUT THIS
INSTITUTION AND WE VERY MUCH
CARE ABOUT THE POLICY.
IMPLICATIONS TO THE WHICH THIS
HAS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LET ME ALSO JUST CLARIFY AND
MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS FUNDAMENTALLY
OPPOSED TO THE IDEAL.
AT THE IDEA OF A AND P.
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE AND YET
THEY HAVE ALSO COME TO THE TABLE --
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS A MEASURED APPROACH AS
IT COMES TO THE FIRST POLICY.
HEARING AS WELL -- TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE.
SAFETY BUT I WANT TO JUST GET
THE A KNOWLEDGE MEANT TO ASK
THAT QUESTION ON THE KEY
PRINCIPLES AND FRAMEWORK I
SHOULD THIS BE THE BILL BE THE
COMMITTEE WHICH IS THAT AGAIN OF
THE REGULATORY STRUCTURE OF THE
BOARD.
THE PATHWAYS TO PRACTICE WHICH
INCLUDES THE AMOUNT OF EDUCATION
AND TRAINING CURRENTLY IN THE
BILL AND THE LIMITED APPLICATION
OF THE CORPORATE BAND IS THAT
CORRECT DOCTOR WHAT IS CORRECT
AND IT SIMPLY TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IS THAT SIMILE TO THE AGREEMENT
OF THE PRINCIPLES.
IN THE FRAMEWORK WORKING
TOGETHER AS IT LEAVE THIS POLICY
COMMITTEE.
PERFECT -- AND SO AGAIN WITH --
THAT NOTE I MADE I KNOW IT
PERHAPS MAYBE PERCEIVE THAT THIS
HAS.
COME ABOUT IN SUCH EASY FASHION
BUT I JUST WANT TO URGE AND GIVE
THIS SENSE PARTICULARLY FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BECAUSE AS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE RUN AROUND
AND AND AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
COMMITTEE IS I JUST CANNOT
EMPHASIZE HOW MUCH OF A WHOLE
HOW MUCH THE HARD WORK OF OUR?
UNDERPAID COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
DONE TO PUT IN THIS ENDEAVOR --
AND HOURS FRANKLY THAT I'VE PUT
IN TO TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
COME TO A LANDING SPOT ON THE
KEY FRAMEWORK TO WHICH AGAIN BMP
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU'VE SEEN THE AUTHOR AND
OPPOSITION AGREED TO AGREE TO
THIS SIMILAR KEY FRAMEWORKS
MOVING HEAD OF COURSE THERE ARE.
SOME OUTSTANDING IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES NONETHELESS THAT'LL MOVE
FORWARD IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT AGAIN I HOPE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO URGE THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION FROM THE
AUTHOR IN OPPOSITION.
AND RESPECTIVE PARTIES ALIKE IN
WITH THAT THAT THIS DOES ENJOY A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AS WELL
AND I CAN THANK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR DILIGENT
CONVERSATIONS.
AND INSIDE AND RECOGNIZING THE
MOVING PIECES OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AT AND WITH RESPECT
I SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT NINETY MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
I KNOW I BRO. FOR NOT VOTING
BLOOM.
CHEN CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING.
DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG?
SEN.
GIPSON AYE.
GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA I'VE MULLIN?
OBERNOLTE.
ABILITY AYE TING.
WHAT HI BUT I [inaudible]
WHAT?
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS NINE
VOTES AND WILL PLACE THE BILL ON
CALL THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL NOW MOVE BACK INTO ORDER
OF FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY BY
AS A MEMBER VOEPEL MISTER VOEPEL
YOUR BILL HAS IT.
AND I RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT.
HOWEVER YOU WISH TO PROCEED.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
MISTER VOEPEL WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF BE AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE -- TODAY I
PRESENT YOU A. B. THREE SEVENTY
WHICH WORKS TO ADDRESS THE FEE
CHARGED BY PHYSICIANS FOR PHILLY
DOT MEDICAL FORMS ACCORDING
APPLICATIONS FOR STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE.
AND THIS REALLY.
AFFECT STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE MORE THAN ALMOST ANY
OTHER MEDICAL FORM.
AND THE REASON IS -- I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL REPLACE THE
CURRENT BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT A PHYSICIAN FROM
CHARGING THEIR PATIENTS MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO
COMPLETE.
A STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
MEDICAL FORM.
THE NEW AMENDMENT WILL REQUIRE A
PHYSICIAN TO CHARGE A REASONABLE
FEE BASED ON THE ACTUAL TIME AND
COST FOR FILLING OUT MEDICAL
FORMS WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
APPLICATION. ZERO AB THREE
SEVENTY WOULD ALSO CLARIFY THAT
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMPLETED MEDICAL FORMS BE MADE
AVAILABLE AT THE LOWEST COST TO
THE PATIENT.
THE GOAL OF THIS MAJORS TO
PROTECT PATIENTS FROM BEING
REQUIRED TO PAY EXISTS COSTS IN
ORDER TO GET A DOCTOR TO FILL
OUT ONE SHEET.
OF PAPER WHICH IS WHAT THE
DOCTORS PORTION OF A DISABILITY
FORM IS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL APPLYING FOR STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE MAY ALREADY
FACE SOME FORM OF WAGE LOSS DUE
TO THEIR DISABILITY THAT'S
ASKING DOCTORS AND PHYSICIANS.
TO CHARGE A REASONABLE FEE TO
FILL OUT THESE FORMS IS HIGHLY
APPROPRIATE.
WITH THAT SAID I'D LIKE TO TAKE.
JUST A SECOND TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK AND ONCE AGAIN YOU'RE
UNDERPAID STAFF THEY DID A GREAT
JOB AT MY UNDERPAID STAFF TO
WORK.
EVERYONE TOGETHER.
WITH THAT I REQUEST THAT I VOTE.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU AS AND
I WILL TELL ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
MOTION IT.
IS THERE SOMEONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT.
OKAY PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE AGAIN THIS IS
CALLING FOR MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE SEVENTY MY NAME IS GRACE
GALLAGHER AMIR DIRECTING
ATTORNEY FOR THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WHERE FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE CONSTITUENCY EITHER REALIZE
OUR APPLIES FOR PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS SUCH AS SSI
CAO WORKS CAO FRESH.
MEDI CAL AN IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
THESE PROGRAMS REGULARLY REQUIRE
THE COMPLETION OF MEDICAL FORMS
BY DOCTORS IF THESE FORMS ARE
NOT COMPLETED THE BENEFITS ARE
TERMINATED.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE DOCTORS ARE
CHARGING AT LEAST A HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO FILL OUT THE FORM
[inaudible]
SO.
THIS COST IS NOT COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
AS SUCH THE POOREST AMONG US ARE
GIVEN A HOBSON'S CHOICE.
EITHER FOR GOLD OR SERVICES THAT
ARE NECESSARY TO LIKE LIVE.
OR PAY THE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
NOT BY MEDICAL NOT.
BY NECESSITIES OF LIFE SUCH AS
EIGHT INSURANCE UTILITIES OR
HOUSING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTY SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE SEVENTY SEE NO WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
PLEASE VOTE AYE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY A
SIMILAR AND WHEN A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THREE SEVENTY MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH LOW HI WELL I BROKE. FOR
AYE BLOOM CHEN JILL CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA?
MEDINA I MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING WHAT.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
VOEPEL.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
MR LACKEY YOUR BILL HAS AND IRA
CONDITION ON BOTH SIDES THE I'LL
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR A
WORKING WITH.
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
AND PROUD TO PRESENT A. B.
THIRTY THREE WHICH URGES THE
BUREAU CANNABIS CONTROL TO
REVISE ITS MINIMUM SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR DISTRIBUTORS.
WHEN CARRYING LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS?
CURRENTLY THERE ARE SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS FOR CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTORS PRESIDENT'S TRANSIT
VEHICLES CANNOT BE VISIBLE OR
IDENTIFIABLE FROM THE OUTSIDE.
EACH STRANDS OF VEHICLE MUST
HAVE AN ALARM SYSTEM.
WHEN A TRANSIT VEHICLES LEFT
UNATTENDED HAS TO BE LOCKED AND
SECURED?
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE FOR SAFETY THERE BEEN
REPEATED INSTANCES OF ROBBERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT'S SAN DIEGO DISTRIBUTOR WAS
BEATEN AND ROBBED OF NINE GRAND.
IN VICTORVILLE DELIVERY DRIVER
WAS ROBBED AT GUNPOINT AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY URGING.
THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TO A CORPORATE ADDITIONAL SAFETY.
OF SECURITY MEASURES SUCH AS
DRESS SYSTEMS ARE HOLD UP ALARM
SO THAT THEIR DISTRIBUTORS ARE
SAFE IN THEIR PRODUCTS DO NOT
FALL INTO THE WRONG HANDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN THIS IS
WE SHOULD BEGIN SUPPORT YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
HAS QUICKLY BECOME A MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY AS WE
KNOW -- WITH PRODUCTS AND MONEY
FLOWING ACROSS THE STATE -- WE
HAVE CLIENTS THAT ARE
TRANSPORTING APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS PER MONTH JUST
TO SEE THE TFA ALONE -- SO THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT SAFETY CONCERNS
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE ASSEMBLY MEN'S OBJECTIVE AND
ENCOURAGE -- I'VE OF TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TAKING ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS AGAIN WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE SEE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM COULD
YOU MEMBERS AT THIS TIME SO YOU
KNOW QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
AS A MEMBER LACKEY JEWISH TO
CLOSE JUST ASK FOR SUPPORT OF
VOTE THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE IS BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SACRI PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE MISSION IS
TO PASS LOW I KNOW I BRO BRO I
BLOOM CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY CUNNINGHAM
AYE DALY.
EGGMAN DALY AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- I MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
WOOD.
THE BILL HAS SIX THOSE WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
AGAIN THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY AND AGAIN FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT UP TO THREE
MINUTES AND FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION UP TO THREE MINUTES
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY ON A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN AN ACT RELATING TO THE
ADVERTISING OF AN LICENSE
CANNABIS BUSINESS.
BUSINESS SAYS I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO APPLY.
TO ALL ADVERTISING PLATFORMS AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR HELPING US WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS AND HELPING US
STRENGTHENED THE BILL I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
COOPER THE BILL AS AMENDED.
I'M AS YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STARTED ISSUING STATE
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE IN THE
STATE.
DESPITE SOME SUCCESS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR OF LEGAL SALES THE
BLACK MARKET HAS CONTINUED TO
FLOURISH DRIVING DOWN THE EAGLE
SALES.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT BY
THE CANNABIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT IS CREATING
A THRIVING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
UNREGULATED UNDERGROUND MARKET.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
NEWS ARTICLES FROM AROUND THE
STATE HAVE DOCUMENTED VIOLENCE
AND CRIME AT THESE ONLINE SAYS
UNLICENSED DISPENSARIES.
IN ADDITION TO THE KIND OF ITS
PRODUCTS SOLD AT THESE LOCATIONS
THEY DO NOT MEET ESTABLISH
QUALITY STANDARDS AND EVADE
STATE TESTING.
COMBATING THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
IS A KEY POLICY GOAL FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE FOR THIS LEGISLATIVE
HERE.
THIS BILL WOULD TARGET THE BLACK
MARKET BY CRACKING DOWN ON A
SPECIFIC PROBLEM THE ADVERTISING
OF THE ILLEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESS.
CERTAIN PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRACTICE IN ADVERTISING LEGAL
OPERATIONS FOR PROFIT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
CLASSIFIED THE ACT OF PUBLISHING
THESE ILLEGAL ADVERTISEMENTS AS
AN UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICE AND
CREATE CIVIL PENALTIES FOR AND
FOR ENTITIES WOULD DECIDE TO
ADVERTISE THE LEGAL OPERATIONS
IN EXCHANGE FOR PROFIT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT SAY
THAT WE ARE TAKING CANNABIS
BLACK MARKET SERIOUSLY IF WE
ALLOW THE REGULAR PROMOTION AND
ADVERTISEMENT OF ILLEGAL
BUSINESSES. TO EXIST WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE
WE KNOW THAT THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS DRUG BUSINESS
TOWARDS THE LEGAL OPERATE
OPERATORS AND MUST FIND A WAY TO
RESTRICT THIS PRACTICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY NINE NOW WILL NOW
TURN -- TO THE MICHAEL RICHARDS
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL YEAH MARIN
PINERA -- WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCACY HERE WITH MY CLIENT IN
A CAN HAS BEEN ASSOCIATION WHO
WOULD DO THAT TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS JARED KILEY LOW
ON THE PRESIDENT THE UNITED CAN
WITH BUSINESS ASSOCIATION I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN THIS BILL IS
NOT TO RESTRICT ADVERTISING IN
TECHNOLOGY OF LEGAL BUSINESSES
THIS BILL IS AN EFFORT TO HOLD A
SMALL NUMBER OF TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
DELIBERATE IGNORANCE.
OF THE CLIENTS THAT FACILITATE
FAIL FOR AND PROFIT OFF THE
ILLEGAL SALE.
CANNABIS LAWS OUR STATE
REGULATED SO THE ADVERTISING
SHOULD BE AS WELL -- SOME OTHER
CITIES AND STATES LIKE THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES HELD A POPULAR
CANNABIS WEBSITE WE'D MAPS
ACCOUNTABLE TO LAWS THAT
RESTRICTED ADVERTISING FOR
UNLICENSED BUSINESSES.
AND THEY COMPLIED OTHER STATES
HAVE HELD THE SAME DEMANDS OF
THIS OF THIS ADVERTISING
PLATFORM AND THEY HAVE COMPLIED
AS WELL SO WHY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DO WE DO WE TELL A
STATE AGENCY THAT THEY WILL NOT
COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
IT'S MONEY.
THEY TAKE TOO MUCH MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ILLEGAL CANNABIS
OPERATIONS TO STOP THE
UNDERMINING OF OUR NEWLY ENACTED
REGULATIONS.
THERE ARE THREE CURRENT --
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS THAT
CURRENTLY ADVERTISE CAMPUS
BUSINESSES YELP AS ONE OF THEM
IT IS FREE OR UP TO THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH TO BE
HAVE A LISTING AS A STATIC MENU
HAS HANDS OFF APPROACH.
IS USER GENERATED RED FLAGS IN
CASE THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
INAPPROPRIATE CONTENT WE'D MAPS
ON THE OTHER HAND CAN TAKE UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
IN CASH.
THEY HAVE A LIVE MENU THEY HAVE
A SHOPPING CART TO FACILITATE
THE DELIVERY THE PRODUCT TO A TO
RESIDENTS NO USER GENERATED RED
FLAG FOR INAPPROPRIATE CONTENT
AND THE PET LEGAL VERSUS ILLEGAL
BUSINESSES AGAINST EACH OTHER.
BY FACILITATING A BIDDING WAR
FOR TOP SPOT FOR ADVERTISING.
I'M WE HAVE RESTRICTED
ADVERTISING FERTILITY
FACILITATING FAILED OF ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY FROM BACK PAGE DOT COM
AND FROM CRAIG'S LIST THE OWNERS
A BACK PAGE SERVE JAIL TIME FOR
THEIR AIDING AND ABETTING OF
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
SO THIS IS NOT A PRECEDENT
SETTING REGULATIONS WE ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO PROFIT OFF IF IF
WE ALLOW BUSINESSES TO PROFIT
OFF THE SKIRTING OF STATE LAW.
THEN IT EMBOLDENED OTHERS TO
ENTER THIS BASE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY NEEDS TO SLOW OR
STOP THE PROLIFERATION.
LIKE ALL THEIR BUSINESS IS
ADAPTING THE CHANGING
REGULATIONS IT IS JUST PART OF
THE JOB I MATH IN THE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
KNOWINGLY AND WILLINGLY
ADVERTISING FREE LEGAL
BUSINESSES.
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE UNDER THIS
PROVISION BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR BUSINESS MODEL WITH
THE FIFTH IN THE FIFTH LETTER
FROM THE BUREAU OF CAMPUS
CONTROL THEY DID NOT COMPLY THAT
IS WHY WE NEED AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN THIS IS THE
KEEP OUR ENFORCEMENT OF OUR
STATE CAMPUS REGULATIONS SILO
INSIDE OUR STATE BORDERS.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE A FEDERAL
ISSUE OTHER STATES HAVE FOUND A
WAY FOR ACCOUNTABILITY SO CAN
CALIFORNIA WITH THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF HELLO THANK
YOU ARE YOU IN YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE OF COURSE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BUILT.
UP OVER TO TRICKLE MAP THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS STATES COUNSELOR
HUNDREDS OF THE FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
I WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
WITH THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY FROM
IT FROM THE OUTSET.
WITH ONE GOAL IN MIND TO RAISE A
CENTER LIVING FOR THE WORKERS TO
CREATE UP TO HELP CREATE AND
REBUILD THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MUCH LIKE WE'VE DONE WITH CLOSER
WORKERS.
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE WORK
WE'RE DOING IN THIS SPACE IS THE
LIST OF MARKET PLACE THIS BILL.
WE THANK.
STRIKE SO A VERY STRONG BLOW
AGAINST THE LIST OF MARKETING --
WE THINK THAT THE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW IT
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE IN TIME AT THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
YES -- DALE GEHRINGER WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMALLY NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOR REFORM OF
MARIJUANA LAWS OR ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMERS WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT THEY BE ACCURATELY INFORMED
AND PROTECTED FROM MISLEADING
ADVERTISING AND BE ABLE TO TELL
THE SHEEP FROM THE GOATS OUT
THERE SO WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AGAIN PLEASE LINE UP.
WHAT IS THIS VERSION IF YOU CAN
SUPPORT?
CHARLES HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT.
SABRINA FANDRICH ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP IN
SUPPORT.
PAUL SMITH WITH RURAL COUNTIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JASON BRYANT'S
HUBBLE COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
CAMPS DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEED JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OUR ASSOCIATION HAS
NO FORMAL POSITION BUT WILL BE
REVIEWING THIS BILL ON THURSDAY
SO WE SHOULD HAVE OF POSITION
SOON THANK YOU.
ANY FINAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SCENE -- WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOW LIKE TO
CALL UP WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WISHING TO SPEAK.
IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN FIGURE
KILEY MAKE SOME ROOM HERE AT THE
DESK AGAIN THIS IS TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BUILT.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN IF YOU WOULD.
KILEY NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
UP TO THREE MINUTES.
TOTAL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JIM HE WORKED
WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET A LETTER IN ON TIME.
WHEN THE BILL WAS SET WE HAVE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO EXPRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE?
ABOUT THAT PROVISION OF THE BILL
WHICH CREATES.
OF STRICT LIABILITY FOR
NEWSPAPERS BROADCASTERS AND
OTHERS -- THROUGH THE
APPLICATION OF AN UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICE REFERENCE.
AND IT.
THE WITH THE WAY THAT IT WOULD
WORK IS -- IF IT IS JUST
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO REQUIRE
A NEWSPAPER -- ADVERTISER I WAS
COULD MEAN.
ADD TAKER OUGHT -- TO YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS IN EACH AND
EVERY AD THAT THEY TAKE -- MOST
ADVERTISEMENT COMING COPY READY --
BUT THIS DOESN'T EVEN REQUIRE
THAT THE NEWSPAPER NO THAT THE
AD WAS -- LEGALLY INFIRM --
THERE'S NO STANDARD APPLIED IF
THE AD RUNS WITH OUT THE
APPLICANTS LICENSE NOW OR THE
LICENSEES LICENSE NUMBER IN THE
AD.
THEN THE NEWSPAPERS
AUTOMATICALLY LIABLE -- THAT'S
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR --
WHAT THIS ATTEMPTS TO DO AND AND
AND BUT LET ME BE CLEAR WE WE
DON'T OPPOSE THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH THIS BILL IS -- BEING
CONSIDERED -- TRYING.
TO CUT BACK OR CURB -- ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES BUT ARE TO DEPUTISE
NEWSPAPERS -- CREATES -- FROM A
PUBLIC POLICY STANDPOINT.
ARE A MUCH WORSE HARM -- THIS IS
A PROBLEM THAT SEEKS LAW
ENFORCEMENT BETTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- FOR IN -- FOR FOR
ENSURING THAT THE LAW IS
FOLLOWED BUT IN DEPUTISING
NEWSPAPERS THAT IS NOT THE
ANSWER AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S
MARK POWERS AND I REPRESENT THE
RADIO AND TELEVISION STATIONS
THAT SERVE YOUR DISTRICTS.
A WE POSE THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE MEDIA
SHOULD NOT BE A REGULATORY ARM
OF GOVERNMENT.
THAT WOULD BE A HUGE CHANGE IN
CURRENT ADVERTISING ALONG THE
RADIO AND TV STATIONS IN YOUR
DISTRICT ARE CONVEYORS OF
INFORMATION.
NOT ENFORCERS OF THE LAW THE
REGULATORY BURDENS YOU IMPOSE
SHOULD ALWAYS FALL ON THE
CREATORS OF THE INFORMATION.
THAT YOU MIGHT THINK THAT
ENSURING AN ADVERTISEMENT HAS A
LICENSE NUMBERS A MINIMAL EFFORT.
BUT IT HAS TO BE AN ACCURATE
LICENSE NUMBER WHICH MEANS
STATIONS COULD NEVER RELY ON THE
ADVERTISER TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
INFORMATION.
ALWAYS HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK WITH
WHATEVER REGULAR RATE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY THERE WAS.
NOW AFTER YOU PASS THIS BILL
IMAGINE THE SAME LOGIC THAT
YOU'RE GONNA APPLY TO REAL
ESTATE AND CONTRACTORS LICENSES
NUMBERS DISCLOSURES AN AUTO ADDS
DISCLOSURES AND POLITICAL ADS.
FOOD BRED **** AND PRODUCT
CLAIMS AND SO ON THE REASON WHY
MEDIA IS NOT PLACED IN THIS
POSITION.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO KNOW THE
SPECIFIC LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
ADVERTISING EVERY POSSIBLE
INDUSTRY AND ITEM FOR SALE.
YOUR STATIONS INFORM ADVERTISERS
WHEN THEY SEE AN ERROR.
AND THEY REFUSE ADS WHEN THOSE
ERRORS ARE NOT CORRECTED.
BUT KNOWING WHAT THOSE COUNTLESS
POSSIBLE REGULATORY ISSUES MIGHT
BE IS NOT THEIR JOB AND
CERTAINLY NOT THE RIVER LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY SO WE ASK FOR NO
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME WITH A
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- MEMBERS -- GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF WE MAPS AND
SIMILAR -- TO MYSTERY OR IT'S
STATEMENT A MOMENT AGO ABOUT NOT
HAVING A LOT OF OPPOSITION AND I
SINCERELY APOLOGIZE TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
FOR ALSO NOT HAVING ONE AND WE
WOULD JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TAKEN AND THE
SPONSORS OF TAKEN.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILL'S FAR
MORE EQUITABLE IN ITS
APPLICATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS MOMENT FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
AND IT AT FIRST WHEN I WAS --
LOOKING AT THE BILL IT SEEMS
LIKE THE THAT IT WAS ADDRESSING
PLATFORMS WITH THE MAIN PURPOSE
WAS GIVING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SALE OF CANNABIS.
BUT THERE ARE -- BUT IF IF I
UNDERSTOOD IT CORRECTLY AND I
CAN BE CORRECTED BECAUSE I JUST
WALKED IN HERE -- THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OTHER SITES ON THE
INTERNET THAT PUT OUT
INFORMATION ON ON MULTITUDE OF
TOPICS BUT ALSO INCLUDE --
CANNABIS AS WELL SO -- WOULD IT
BE.
AND IT MAY BE THE AMENDMENTS
ALREADY ACCOMPLISH THIS WOULD BE
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
ADDRESS THE EXPANSION -- TO BE
ABLE TO CAPTURE.
ANY PLATFORM THAT IS PROMOTING
THE SALE OF CANNABIS INSTEAD OF
LIMITING IT TO JUST CERTAIN
PLATFORMS AND IS IT SO THAT THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THAT.
YES MISTER GRAYSON THE CURRENT A
COMMITTEE MEN MEANS THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS AGREED ACCEPTED --
HAVE IT TO BE MORE ENCOMPASSING
OF THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT WELL
THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
ANY REPETITIOUS -- TESTIMONY
THERE AND I THINK YOU TO THE
OFFICE FOR BRING THE SUPPORT OF
THE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
NUMBER WOULD YOU WISH TO ADD ON
AND ANY ADDITIONAL AYE LOOKING
YES THAT THAT THAT'S WHY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A
THROUGH THE WEEKEND -- TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS ALL OF
THE ISSUES AND AGAIN I THINK
THAT THE OTHER COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THAT CHAIR -- FOR BEING --
WILLING TO HELP ME -- CLARIFY
THIS AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET IT
TO THE NEXT STEP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SOMEONE WOMAN I'M.
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS -- I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT ON ALL OF US TO TRY
AND ENFORCE COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING LAWS AND AND REDUCE.
THE ADVERTISING OF NON LICENSE
SERVICES.
I HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THAT THAT YOU WERE AWARE
OF UP IN BOTH MY CONCERN AND
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF AND
REYES BY THE OPPOSITION.
SO.
I I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
REQUIRING A SOPHISTICATED
PLATFORM LIKE WE'D MAPS TO
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA LAW
REGARDING CANNABIS I THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO EXPECT THAT THEY
WOULD BE EXPERTS ON WHAT THAT
LAW SAYS BUT OTHER ADVERTISING
PLATFORMS I'M NOT SURE THAT IT'S
REASONABLE AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE.
I THAT IS YOU KNOW I COME FROM A
VERY SMALL TOWN.
I ONE OF THE SMALLEST IN MY
DISTRICTS AND AND WE HAVE ONE
PAPER IN TOWN THE BIG BEAR
GRIZZLY -- IT'S GOT A
CIRCULATION OF JUST A COUPLE OF
THOUSAND COPIES IT ONLY COMES
OUT ONCE A WEEK.
SO -- FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT
LET'S SAY THE SOMEONE ADVERTISES
CANNABIS FOR SALE IN THE GRIZZLY
I DON'T THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
EXPECT THAT THEY WOULD BE.
EXPERTS ON CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
LAW AND MY READING OF THE BILL
LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THAT IF THEY
WERE TO ALL MET.
THE LICENSE NUMBER ALTHOUGH THE
ADVERTISER WOULD IF THEY WERE TO
MAKE A LIGHT THEIR LICENSE
NUMBER.
AND THE GRIZZLY WERE NOT TO
CATCH IT -- AND THEY WERE TO
CORRECT THAT IF THAT AIR WAS
BROUGHT TO THEIR ATTENTION THEY
WERE CORRECT AT THE VERY NEXT
ISSUE THAT SEVEN DAYS A TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY THEY
BE LIABLE.
FOR ALMOST TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN -- AND CIVIL
PENALTIES AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S THAT'S REASONABLE.
YEAH I ALSO.
TO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
RIGHT A PRIVATE ACTION IN THE
BILL.
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED THAT --
RATHER THAN GOING AFTER THE
SOPHISTICATED ACTORS LIKE WE
PERHAPS THAT WILL HAVE OPEN THE
DOOR TO LAW FIRMS GOING AFTER
THE UNSOPHISTICATED ACTORS LIKE
THE BIG BEAR GRIZZLY THE
THOUSANDS OF OTHER NEWSPAPERS.
Là SIMILAR THEM ACROSS THE
STATE SO THAT'S MY CONCERN AND I
REALLY WISH THAT -- THAT THAT
THE BILL HAD BEEN NARROWED A
LITTLE BIT TO RECOGNIZE SOME OF
THE TRADE OFFS THERE BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO BE SUPPORTED BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO BE.
TODAY BECAUSE OF THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER WOULD KNOW TO YES I I
AGREE AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE THE COMMITTEE
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
THIS BILL IS STILL GOING TO DO
JUDICIARY AND I'M.
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR HAS --
AGREED TO WORK WITH ME ON TRYING
TO FIGURE THAT OUT BY IT I I
THINK THE BIGGER PICTURE I AGREE
WITH YOU BUT THE BIGGER PICTURE
IS THAT -- WE ARE ADVERTISING ON
REGULATED -- DISTRIBUTORS AND
THIS IS DANGEROUS NOT JUST. FOR
SELF BUT SOME OF THESE THESE --
PRODUCTS ARE NOT TESTED SO IT'S
DANGEROUS TO THE HEALTH OF THE
COMMUNITY AND SO I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND WOULD
LOVE TO SIT DOWN AND TALK TO YOU
ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THIS IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE BUT AT THIS TIME
THIS IS THE ONLY I THINK THE
ONLY AVENUE TO BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION WE HAD A SIMILAR
BILL LAST YEAR?
AND BUT THAT IS NOT BEING
COMPLIED WITH BECAUSE THEY HAVE --
I THINK THE THE VENDOR WITH
SAYING THAT IT'S WE DON'T HAVE A
RIGHT TO REGULATE THE ONLINE
PLATFORM SENSE OF THEY'RE NOT
COMPLYING WITH BAD BECAUSE OF
THE ONLINE.
ONLINE REGULATION BY THE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS FOR ME MY CONCERN
IS FIRST AND FOREMOST THE HEALTH
OF THE COMMUNITY SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS ARE NOT BEING TESTED IN
ITS.
ITS POISON AND SOUL SOUL WE HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESTRICT
THESE VENDORS AND I AGREE WITH --
THE SMALL ADVERTISERS BUT YOU
KNOW JUST IN MY HEAD I'M
THINKING IF YOU WERE GOING TO
ACCEPT ADVERTISEMENTS THERE
SHOULD BE -- YOU DON'T JUST SEND
IN AN ADVERTISEMENT AND SENT
MONEY YOU HAVE TO DO A CONTRACT.
OR AT LEAST -- YOU HAVE TO
SUPPLY THE INFORMATION OF WHO
THE VENDOR IS AND THE AND THE
PAYMENT.
IT'S JUST LIKE YOU ASK FOR A
CREDIT CARD NUMBER YOU CAN ASK
FOR A VENDOR.
LICENSE NUMBER AND IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT THEN.
THE THE BIG BEAR GRIZZLY CAN CAN
CHECK BACK THAT IS AN ONLINE
PLATFORM BAD -- THE STATE
PROVIDES WHERE THEY CAN CHECK
THE LICENSES OF THOSE VENDORS
SOLD FOR ME.
AGAIN I'M NOT IN THAT ARENA BUT
IT SEEMS SIMPLE ENOUGH THAT IF
YOU'RE PROVIDING A CONTRACT TO
THESEPEOPLE WHEN THEY ADVERTISE
THAT THEY THEY NEED TO INCLUDE
THEIR THEIR CANNABIS LICENSOR
LEVIN WE COMPLETELY AGREE ABOUT
THAT BUT THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE
TO KNOW THAT THAT IS A STATE.
REQUIREMENTS.
AND ADVERTISERS COME IN ALL
DIFFERENT SHAPES AND SIZES FOR
ALL DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICES
AND TO EXPECT A A SMALL
NEWSPAPER TO KNOW ABOUT ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS IN
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT AREAS OF
STATE LAW.
I THINK IS NOT REASONABLE ONE SO
WELL.
TRUE I THINK WE SHARE THE SAME
GOAL YES SO I I'M I'M CONVINCED
THAT MAYBE THERE'S A MIDDLE
GROUND THERE RIGHT SO I'LL SEE
IT AGAIN AND JUDICIARY ON I'D
WELCOME THE CONVERSATION AND AND
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO TO FIND A
WAY -- THAT WERE REASONABLE WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE KINDS OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT'S THAT STILL
ACCOMPLISHES THE AIM OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME -- AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION ON THE A DIALOGUE
THAT JUST OCCURRED THE COMMITTEE
MEN'S ARE SILENT ON THE
PROVISIONS MISTER OBERNOLTE THAT
YOU THAT JUST ADDRESS WITH THE
AUTHOR.
I SAID THESE ARE DIFFERENT
DISCUSSIONS -- SHOULD IT BEFORE
IN THE JUDICIARY -- BUT NONE THE
LESS -- CONTINUE CONVERSATION
CENA ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REVIEWED YOU WISH.
TO NO THANK YOU I JUST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN --
I APPRECIATE THAT WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THAT THE SPECIFICS
OF THE AMENDMENTS AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE AND
CONVERSATION.
SHOULD MOVE TO THE JUDICIARY AND
WOULD LIKE TO CO AUTHOR OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION I SHOULD
HAVE PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE NOW NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY ONE EGGMAN.
IS THERE A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER WENT COMMITTEE
SEXTAPE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY LOW
HI WELL I BRO BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
DOLLY.
EGGMAN WHEN I FONG.
PHONE UP DURING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
GREAT GRAYSON AYE [inaudible]
HOLDEN IRWIN.
HI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NO TING [inaudible]
WHAT? EIGHT TO ONE BELIEVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO
WHEN I MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
AND AGAIN FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT UP TO THREE MINUTES AND
WHEN THIS IS AN OPPOSITION UP TO
THREE MINUTES ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
GOOD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE YOU TODAY
ON THIS BILL -- THIS BILL STANDS
OUT FOR ME BECAUSE IT'S FOR
REFLECTS AN AREA OF CONCERN AND
POLICY THAT I WORKED ON FOR MORE
THAN FIFTEEN YEARS.
I'VE COURSE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE FOUNDING OF A CITY.
DESIGNED TO PROMOTE LOCAL
CONTROL THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO SET.
GOALS FOR THE CHARACTER OF LIFE
IN OUR COMMUNITY -- AND THAT'S
THE THIS BILL FIFTY THIRD
RELATES.
TO WHAT I BELIEVE IS THE POLICY
THAT WAS SET IN MOTION BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH THE VOTE ON
A. B. TWO SIX SIX WHEN I WAS THE
AUTHOR OF IT WE EVENTUALLY
SHIFTED AUTHORSHIP.
I GAVE THAT BILL ABOUT CALLING
MR BONTA.
BUT WHEN THE BILL WAS FIRST
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LOCAL CONTROL
MEDICAL MARIJUANA BILL PASSED BY
A THIRTEEN TO ONE VOTE -- ANY
OTHER BILL ONLY GARNERED NINE
VOTES.
SO REALLY THE WHOLE CHEMISTRY OF
MEDICAL MARIJUANA BACK IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THAT COURSE WAS
SET BY THE ASSEMBLY BMP
COMMITTEE.
WHEN YOU CAME DOWN VERY SHARPLY
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL CONTROL?
ON THE SUBJECT MATTER THAN MORE
GENERALLY OF MARIJUANA IS
SOMETHING I'VE WORKED ON FOR
QUITE AWHILE.
BACK IN TWENTY TEN YOU MAY
RECALL THERE WAS A BALLOT
PROPOSITION DEAL WITH MEDICAL
DEAL WITH RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA.
AND I ACTUALLY DID A OVERVIEW
THAT BALLOT MEASURES IT WORKED
ITS WAY ON TO CALIFORNIA CHOICES
DOT ORG OR STATEWIDE WEBSITES.
FOCUSED ON POLICY CONVERSATION.
ALSO IN TWENTY TEN I SUPPORTED.
PUT ON THE BALLOT AS MAYOR A
LOCAL ORDINANCE RETRO A TAX ON
MARIJUANA CULTIVATION.
WHICH PASSED IT BY MORE THAN 55%
[inaudible]
SO.
AS I APPROACH THIS ISSUE AND
THIS BILL.
THE CENTERPIECE OF AB TWO SIX
SIX THE MEDICAL MARIJUANA BILL.
THAT WAS SET IN MOTION BY THIS
COMMITTEES VOTE IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN WAS A CENTERPIECE
OF WHAT WENT TO THE GOVERNOR I
ACTUALLY WROTE THE GOVERNOR THAT
YEAR.
SPEAKING OF AB TWO SIX SIX THAT
ENSURES A STATE AND LOCAL
LICENSE MUST BE IN PLACE FOR
MEDICAL MARIJUANA BUSINESS TO
OPERATE.
THAT'S CREDIBLE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS WAS AN ALMOST TWENTY YEAR
IMPASSE ON MEDICAL MARIJUANA
YEAR TO YEAR THE LECTURES AND
FAILED TO ADOPT RULES.
BOARD THAT LOCAL CONTROL
PROTECTION AT THE HEART OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN DEAL THAT WENT TO
THE GOVERNOR HE SIGNED INTO LAW.
THIS TO ME IS WHY THE PROPONENTS
OF PROP [inaudible]
SIXTY FOUR IN.
SIXTEEN SAID AS THEY DID SAY.
THAT IT WOULD PROTECT THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY.
THAT IS WHAT THE BALLOT
ARGUMENTS SAID.
THAT IS WHAT THE SO THE
ARGUMENTS MADE ON BEHALF OF BY
THE PROPONENTS SAID OF PROTECT
ALL CONTROL.
THE LA OWES IMPARTIAL BALLOT.
STATEMENTS SAID THE SAME THING
[inaudible]
AND I HAVE ALWAYS BELIEVED
THAT.
THIS LEGISLATURE.
BY SAFEGUARDED LOCAL CONTROL SO
THE LOCALS DO NOT ACTUALLY FEEL
THREATENED.
BY STATE LICENSURE.
BY LOCAL NOT HAVING A GRIPE
ABOUT STATE REGULATION AS I
COULD MOST ARE YOU SURE THEY
GRIPE ABOUT THE A. B. C.'S.
APPROVAL OF NEW LIQUOR STORES
AND BARS IN CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH VERY LITTLE.
SAY.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY DIDN'T GO
DOWN THAT TRAIL OF TAKEN AWAY
LOW CONTROLLERS SAFEGUARDED.
AND EVEN IN THE COURSE OF THE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA CONVERSATION.
MY ASSIST WAS ALWAYS.
I HAD TWO GUIDING PRINCIPLES A
GUIDED THAT WHOLE CONVERSATION
AND THIS BILL TIES INTO IT.
SAFEGUARD LOCAL CONTROL.
AND IF YOU SAFEGUARD LOCAL
CONTROL WHAT YOU'LL GET IS SOME
JURISDICTIONS MAY BE MORE
COMFORTABLE EARLIER.
BUT THEY WILL SHOW HOW THESE
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY DO WORK.
SO THE PARADE OF HORRIBLE'S THAT
LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE THEIR MINDS
ABOUT HOW BAD THESE BUSINESS ARE.
CAN GET SORTED OUT THEY JUST
REALIZE OKAY MY APPREHENSIONS
ARE NOT WELL FOUNDED IN FACT.
AND THIS WILL ALLOW OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE RESISTANT
AT FIRST TO KIND OF FALL INTO
LINE [inaudible]
AND THIS BILL.
WHICH WILL SAFEGUARD THAT
ABILITY MAINTAIN A BAND IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
ALSO INCORPORATES A BUDGET ASK
FOR GRANTS. TO SUPPORT LOCALS AS
A START OPEN UP THIS MARKET TO
GET SOME HELP ON ENFORCEMENT.
SO THIS BILL CARRIES OUT THE
VISION THAT I WAS AT THE HEART
OF BY ADVOCACY AND AND PROP.
TWO SIX SIX RESPECT LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME TRY TO WOO
THE LOCALS TO GET PASTOR PRAYED
FOR BULLS DEAL WITH THE REALITY.
AND THIS TO ME IS A MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE LONG TERM STRATEGY
FOR HOW WE AS LAWMAKERS.
CAN FIND A WAY TO ADVANCE PUBLIC
POLICY WITHOUT.
CREATING CONFLICTS BELOW THE
COMPLEX WORK THEMSELVES OUT BY
ADROIT LEADERSHIP -- I WANT TO
SAY THAT THE DECISION OF THIS
COMMITTEE AT THAT.
AT THAT FIRST TERRY TO PASS.
THE BILL OVERWHELMINGLY THE HEAD
LOCAL CROLLES HEART.
PLAYED OUT IN OUR HOUSE
DRAMATICALLY BECAUSE COME JUNE.
WHEN THE SENATE WAS MOVING A
BILL DEALING WITH MEDICAL
MARIJUANA?
THE AUTHOR IN THE END THAT HOUSE
MUSTARD A PRETTY GOOD VOTE OF
THE SENATE FOR ON THE SAME DAY
ARE VOTE WAS TAKEN.
THEY GOT A TWO TO ONE VOTE
TWENTY SIX TO THIRTEEN AND FOR
THE SENATE.
GOOD JOB BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
BUT ON THAT DAY IN OUR HOUSE.
THE ASSEMBLY PASSED.
THE MEDICAL MARIJUANA BILL OF
LOCAL CONTROLS HEART.
SIXTY TWO TO EIGHT SO WE
ACTUALLY SIDE WITH LOCAL CONTROL.
BROUGHT PEOPLE THE MIDDLE.
AND ACTUALLY CREATED THE
MOMENTUM THAT EXPLAINS WHY THE
PROPONENTS OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
SUPPORTED IT.
RODE INTO SIXTY FOR USE IN THEIR
ARGUMENTS WHY THE LA -- SOUGHT
THEIR AND AND IT'S WHY I NOW
BRING THIS BILL ST I'M STILL A
PROPONENT OF PRESERVING LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT I STILL HAVE IN MIND THIS
LONG TERM STRATEGY AS YOU
RESPECT LOCAL CONTROL.
YOU CAN.
ENCOURAGE JURISDICTIONS YOU KNOW
THEY WERE SORT OF JAMMED UP WITH
THE WAY PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS
PASSED.
THEY HAD TO HAVE A POLICY IN
PLACE BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A SHORT TIME FRAME LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADOPT SOMETHING.
YOU CAN TRY TO GET A NEW US
POLICY WHICH INVARIABLY TAKES A
LONG TIME A LOT OF CONVERSATION.
WE JUST GO THE BAN.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THE
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE BANDS I DON'T ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT REPRESENTS LONG
TERM ANIMUS.
TOWARDS THIS POLICY CHANGE THAT
THE VOTERS OF BRACED.
I SEE THAT AS EXPEDIENT REACTION.
TO FILL IN THE CLOCK LOOMING.
AND JUST TAKE IT A STEP TO KIND
OF INSURE THAT LOCAL CONTROL WAS
RESPECTED.
AND SO TO ME THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A LONG ONGOING EFFORT
ON MY OWN PART TO KIND OF WORK
IN THIS BASED RESPECT LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT THE SAME TIME TO ADVANCE
POLICY AND TO AVOID TRAIN WRECKS.
AND JUST SUPPORT DISABILITY FOR
ALL.
EVERY ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
OF ALL FIVE HUNDRED CITIES TO
KIND OF TAKE A MORE [inaudible]
STOP HYPERVENTILATING.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE PRINTER
HORRIBLE.
FOCUS ON THE FACTS AND MAKE SOME
SPECIFIC DECISIONS.
AND ON THE ISSUE OF OF THEM
ACCESS TO MEDICAL MARIJUANA I DO
WANT TO SAY [inaudible]
THAT.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT EVEN
MAJOR SEARCH WHICH BANDS
CULTIVATION A COMMERCIAL SENSE
CANNOT BAN.
CULTIVATE FOR PRIVATE USE WHICH
IS THE RIGHT TO FIFTEEN AFFORDED.
AND I WOULD SAY THERE'S ACTUALLY
NO MEMBER IN THE ORIGINAL GANG
OF FIVE WORK ON THIS.
THAT WAS MORE PERSISTENT INSANE
DO NOT LOSE TRACK OF ACCESS TO
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
INDEED IN THE BILL THAT WE SENT
THE GOVERNOR MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
THE BILL PROVIDED FOR A TASK
FORCE TO HELP ADVICE TO BUREAU.
REGARDED ISSUES A PATIENT ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY WHICH WAS A
PROVISION I INSISTED BE THERE.
AND EVEN PROP SIXTY FOUR DOES
NOT STATE OVER RULED THAT.
IT DOES SAY THEY TRIED TO
STREAMLINE THINGS THAT SORT OF
THING BUT SOUL.
I ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT.
ACCESS TO MEDICAL MARIJUANA IS
IMPORTANT.
UC SAN DIEGO HAS THE MEDICAL.
CANNABIS RESEARCH INSTITUTE
[inaudible]
OUR WHICH ESTABLISHES THAT
THERE'S GREAT MANY FUNCTIONALITY
CAN RISE AND USE OF CANNABINOIDS
AND CANNABIS. TO DEAL WITH
EPILEPSY AND MANY OTHER
AFFLICTIONS.
IN A WAY THAT'S ACTUALLY
SUPERIOR TO MORE OPIOID BASED
THING SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
ENCOURAGED THAT.
SO THAT IS MY BACKSTORY ON THE
BILL -- I FEEL REFLECTS.
AS I SAY.
AN INTEREST IN QUALITY OF LIFE
LOCALLY THAT IS WHY I AM
ACTUALLY MEMBER TODAY BECAUSE IT
PROFIT RUN FORMA CITY AND THEN
[inaudible]
BECOME MAYOR.
THIS INTEREST A MARIJUANA GOING
BACK TO TWENTY TEN ONE NINETEEN
WAS ON ABOUT.
AND I PUT MY OWN LOCAL ORDINANCE --
AND YET I'M STILL WORK OF THIS
IDEA OF PROTECT THE LOCAL
CURRENT CONTROL THE ONE HAND HOW
DO YOU WILL -- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FEEL THEY CAN
PUT THEIR TOLL ON THE WATER.
GET PAST THEIR FEARS.
AND BROADNESS REACH I THINK
THAT'S A LONG SUSTAINABLE
STRATEGY.
AND I KNOW I HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN SUPPORT SO I WILL JUST.
INVITE THEIR COMMON I THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THREE
MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TROUT HARVEY IN
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THIS BILL A SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES -- AN ENTIRELY NEW
POLICY -- THAT ALLOWS FOR
CANNABIS TO BE TO BE DELIVERED
STATEWIDE -- REGARDLESS OF ANY
CITY OR COUNTY PROHIBITION OR
LIMITING ORDINANCE -- ON SUCH
ACTIVITY -- NOW AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED AT AS PASSED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE A U. M. A. --
AND POWER THE LEGISLATURE ACTION
TOO MANY INITIATIVE -- BY EITHER
SIMPLE MAJORITY OR TWO THIRDS
VOTE I DEPENDING ON THE SPECIFIC
NATURE OF THOSE AMENDMENTS --
BUT ONLY IF THE MEASURE FURTHERS
THE PURPOSE -- AND INTENT OF THE
ACT YOU KNOW OTHERWISE THE
VOTERS THEMSELVES MUST WEIGH IN --
AS WE'VE YOU IT'S HARDLY
ARGUABLE THAT THAT THE RULE AND
AND QUESTION THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SIX TWO DIRECTOR -- FIVE
YOU KNOW BILLS THE FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND AND AND INTENT OF OF
THE ADULT USE MARIJUANA ACT AND
SO -- YOU KNOW MOREOVER UNLIKE.
VIRTUALLY ALL OTHER NEWLY
ESTABLISHED CANNABIS POLICY --
THIS POLICY AT ISSUE WAS CREATED
IN A REGULATORY VACUUM BY THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
DEVOID OF ANY THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATIVE.
CONVERSATION OR DEBATE --
CONSEQUENTLY BY HAPHAZARDLY
REMOVING A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REASONABLE REGULATORY AUTHORITY
ON CANNABIS DELIVERIES -- IT
WILL BE C. IS IMPOSE A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH -- TO ALL TO
CANVASS REGULATION THAT REALLY
DOESN'T REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE POPULATION AND WIDE
SPECTRUM OF THE POINTS ON THE
TOPIC.
NOW FROM THE LEAGUE'S HE POINT
THERE A FEW CONCERNS THAT
UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION -- FIRST THE STATE
WIDE DELIVERY REGULATION SERVES
AND OURS THE NATION AS A BROKEN
PROMISE TO THOSE WHO PASSED PROP
SIXTY FORMED UNDER THE BELIEF
THAT LOCAL AUTHORITY WOULD BE
PRESERVED -- THE STATE OF THE A
YOU I'M A GUARANTEE THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS YOU KNOW PURSUANT
TO THE CREATION AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF A DUAL
LICENSING STRUCTURE WOULD BE
ABLE TO ALLOW.
REGULATE OR PROHIBIT ANY AND ALL
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITIES WITHIN
THEIR RESPECTIVE.
COMMUNITIES.
AND WAS REALLY ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THE MEASURE RECEIVED THE
SUPPORT THAT IT DID FROM CITIES
AND COUNTIES -- THE REGULATION
AT ISSUE EFFECTIVELY STRIP THAT
LOCAL DECISION MAY AUTHORITY
AWAY -- FROM LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND REALLY SERVES THE CLEAR
OVERREACH THE BCC AND ULTIMATELY
MADE FOR AN UNJUSTIFIED
EXPANSION OF EXISTING LAW
[inaudible]
THIS.
SURE ONE MINUTE LEFT.
SO I MEAN REALLY IN OUR
ESTIMATION CURRENT RULE IS
CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT -- WHERE
THE ILLICIT MARKET CAN GROW AND
THRIVE WITHOUT FEAR OF CRIMINAL
CONSEQUENCE -- WHICH IS THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT PROP SIXTY FOUR
YOU KNOW START TO START -- TO TO
ACHIEVE.
AND SO YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY WOULD RECTIFY THE
IMPACT OF OF ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT JUST CITIES
WITH BANDS BUT THOSE WITH MANY
ORDINANCES AND EVEN THOSE WHO
AUTHORIZED DELIVERY WERE TRYING
TO PROTECT THOSE LOCAL OPERATORS
FROM.
HAVING TO COMPETE NOT JUST
AGAINST ILLICIT MARKET PLACE BUT
THE AGAINST OTHERWISE LEGITIMATE
OPERATORS FROM OUT OF
JURISDICTION -- AND SO WHAT THE
LEAGUE IS NEITHER PRO NOR ANTI
CANNABIS BUT THIS IS ABOUT
RESTORING THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUT TO REASON THE
REGULATE AS THEY SEE FIT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IN SECONDS MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAUL SMITH WITH THE ROLE
COUNTIES ASSOCIATION WE WERE
ALSO AT THE PARTY -- IN TERMS OF
THE CRAFTING THE M. ZERO SAID
THING ON ONE OF JUST REAL
QUICKLY BUILD UPON -- SOMETHING
THAT -- MISTER COOLEY SAID WHEN
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED HIS
LEGISLATION.
THE THE PRESUMPTION WAS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAD TO ACT TO
PROHIBIT MOBILE DELIVERIES PROP
SIXTY FOUR COMES ALONG AND
CHANGES THAT PRESUMPTION BUT
IT'S STILL PRESERVES LOCAL
CONTROL WHAT WHAT MR CALL THESE
REALLY ASKING FOR HERE IS NOT TO
GO BACK TO THE M. SIERRA SAY BUT
JUST REAFFIRM.
WHAT BOB SIXTY FOUR SAYS WE
WOULD URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU ANY?
JUST A QUICK COMMENT CARE MARTIN
ST ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WE'LL JUST SAY THAT WE ARE
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE IN THIS
REGULATORY PROGRAM I'M SERIOUS
SAME PROP SIXTY FOUR WERE
FOUNDED SORT OF ON A PROMISE OF
THAT PARTNERSHIP OF LOCAL
CONTROL.
WE ARE TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE
SPOKES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
REGULATING TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND CRAFT REALLY REASONABLE --
APPROACHES TO AT INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO GET OUT OF THE ILLICIT
MARKET INTO THE REGULATED MARKET
PLACE WE FEEL THIS BILL RESPECTS
THE INTENT OF SIXTY FOUR AND
CERSEI ND MATT KERR SO I AYE
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL -- YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIFTEEN THIRTY AGAIN ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WISHING TO
SPEAK ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN THIRTY MR TURN MEMBERS
SILVIUS ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SING AT NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NOW LIKE TO CALL IT
WOULD THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
WHAT IS AN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD KINDLY MAKE ROOM AT THE
TABLE OF?
OR OR THE LIKE
. ONE OF THE
YOU'LL HEAR ME.
MAKERS OF COUPLE [inaudible]
REMAINS.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR AGAIN WILL
PROVIDE UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL FOR ALL TESTIMONY AT THE
TABLE IN OPPOSITION SO PLEASE
FEEL FREE 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
FOR HAS LONG STANDING COMMITMENT
TO DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK FOR
THE REGULATION AND LICENSURE OF
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS.
MR COOLEY WAS ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL -- FIVE WHO BELIEVE
THAT A REGULATED SYSTEM WAS
ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING IMPORTANT
STATE PUBLIC POLICY OBJECTIVES
THAT SUPPORT A THRIVING LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WHILE
ENHANCING PUBLIC AND CONSUMER
SAFETY.
THIS IS PRECISELY WHY CCA'S
OBJECTIVE WHEN THE ORGANIZATION
WAS FOUNDED -- TO TO YOU KNOW
SUPPORT A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
WHICH IS WHY WE SADLY AND MUST
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TODAY.
AS HE NOTED A KEY CORNERSTONE OF
THIS FRAMEWORK IS LOCAL CONTROL
FOR THE RECORD CCA HAS NEVER
OPPOSED LOCAL CONTROL.
IN FACT AS THE MEDICINAL
FRAMEWORK WAS BEING DEVELOPED
OVER FOUR YEARS AGO CCA WORKED
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ASSOCIATIONS
INCLUDING THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES TO MAKE THIS
FRAMEWORK A REALITY.
UNFORTUNATELY NO ONE ANTICIPATED
HOW FEW CITIES AND COUNTIES
WHICH ULTIMATELY CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE.
AFTER SIXTEEN MONTHS -- SINCE
THEY DON'T USE TOOK AFFECT WE
ARE SEEING CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLIANT CANNABIS INDUSTRY
CONTRACT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
JUST 20% OF OUR STATE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE AUTHORIZING SOME
FORM OF COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY AND LEAD EVEN LESS ARE
AUTHORIZING COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
RETAIL.
ACCORDING TO STATISTICS OBTAINED
BY THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL JUST YESTERDAY JUST
UNDER A THOUSAND RETAIL LICENSES
HAVE BEEN ISSUED STATEWIDE.
AND SANTA CLARA THEIR EIGHT WE
TELL LICENSES -- IN ONE CITY OF
FIFTEEN CITIES IN KERN THERE ARE
THREE REAL RETAIL LICENSES IN
ONE OF ELEVEN CITIES AND LA
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE AND TWENTY OF
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES.
IN ORANGE COUNTY THIRTY
RETAILERS IN ONE CITY OF
APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTY FOUR IN SAN BERNADINO
FOURTEEN RETAILERS AND THREE OF
TWENTY FOUR CITIES WITH THE
RATIO OF AND RETAIL LICENSE PER
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED RESIDENTS.
A NO VOTE ON AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
WILL NOT IMPROVE THESE A VISIBLE
STATISTICS HOWEVER OPPOSING THIS
BILL TODAY WILL UPHOLD LOCAL
CONTROL.
CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL STILL
BE ABLE TO BAN BROKEN WATER
CANNABIS FACILITIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AT THE SAME TIME AND NO VOTE
WILL ENSURE THAT CANNABIS
CONSUMERS AND PATIENTS CONTINUE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN TRACKED
TESTED PROPERLY LABELED AND
CONTAINED IN CHILD RESISTANT
PACKAGING.
IT WILL FURTHER ENSURE THAT
CANNABIS OPERATORS HAVE VERIFIED
THAT THE CONSUMER IS OVER.
TWENTY ONE FOR THESE REASONS CCA
STRONGLY OPPOSES AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY AND URGES HERE NO VOTE
TODAY TWENTY SECOND [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AN
CANKER I'M A PARENT OF OR FOUR
SONS ONE OF WHOM HAS EPILEPSY.
AND I'M FROM FORMER A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER AND I CHAIR
THE COMMISSION SPECIAL ED HERE --
I AM NOW A VERY MUCH A PART OF
EPILEPSY CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
PUBLIC POLICY RECOGNIZE UP
COALITION I RECOGNIZE UNIFIED
VOICE.
OF THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WITH
EPILEPSY.
IF FIFTEEN THIRTY IS CODIFIED
INTO LAW THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
EPILEPSY WHO CANNOT DRIVE
BECAUSE OF THEIR SEIZURES WILL
FACE THE RISK OF SUFFERING LIFE
THREATENING SEIZURES DUE TO THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO CANNABIS.
IN A TIMELY AND ACCOMMODATING
PROCESS VIA DO A DELIVERY SYSTEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
BOB HIM DEAL DURING A WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMAL ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL ARE CO AUTHORS OF
PROPOSITION.
TWO FIFTEEN ALL LET ME JUST
BEGIN BY SAYING WE HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THE MEAT OF THIS
BILL REGARDING THE ENFORCEMENT
KRANZ.
ARE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
CERTAINLY HAS TO BE ATTENDED TO
OUR ONLY ISSUE IS WITH THANK YOU
THE VERY MUCH AND I AND ON THE
LIVE REGISTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS TABLE HAS EXCEEDED
YOUR THREE MINUTES OF TOTAL
MONEY NOT EFFICIENT AS I STATED.
MULTIPLE TIMES SO WILL NOW GO TO
THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE LINED UP --
FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION NAME AN
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR CHAUVET
HOOVER REPRESENTING THE GRAZERS
SACRAMENTO ALS ASSOCIATION AND
PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR.
WE REPRESENT OVER THIRTY
COUNTIES -- FORGIVE I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE AS MY VOICE IS
BEEN AFFECTED BY ALS.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB -- FIFTEEN
THIRTY AND A UNIFIED VOICE OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WITH A LS AND NERO G..
D. GENDER IT DID DISEASES IN
THIS STATE.
I'M HERE TO PUT A HUMAN FACE ON
THIS BILL.
IF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY YEARS.
CODIFIED INTO LAW INDIVIDUALS
WITH A ALAS WHO CANNOT DRIVE.
WE'LL HAVE OUR ACCESS TO
CANNABIS RESTRICTED OR ENDING.
A MEDICAL CARVE OUT FOR THIS
BILL WILL NOT DO ANYTHING. TO
STOP THE ILLICIT MARKET AND
DOESN'T CONTRIBUTE TO ENSURING
CARE.
IS DELIVERED IN A SAFE REGULATED
WAY AS A PATIENT.
PHYSICIAN INTENSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU I I
WOULD ASK FOR MORE TIME SINCE
I'M UNABLE TO SPEAK QUICKLY YES
NO IS BLOWN PROBLEM YOU'VE
YOU'VE REGISTERED YOUR
OPPOSITION SO WE HAVE A LONG
LINE BEHIND YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PROVIDING YOUR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION WHEN OUR NEXT TO CALL
UP THE NEXT PERSON IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
CANNERY GRABS THE NOR CAL
CANNABIS STRONGLY OPPOSED WE ARE
A LICENSED NON STOREFRONT
DELIVERY.
YEAH YES I REMEMBER.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY FRIEDMAN AND
I'M REPRESENTING JEDI EXTRACTS.
LOCAL AUTHORITIES NEED TO
SUPPORT AND MEANS OF SAFE AND IS
FULL ACCESS OF CANNABIS TO THEIR
LOCAL HOME BOUND TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS WHOSE LIVES CRITICALLY
RIVER.
OF RELY ON THIS FORM OF
MEDICATION REQUIRING THESE
PATIENTS TO GROW AT THEIR AT
THEIR OWN HOME IS NOT AN OPTION.
IT UNDERMINES THE SEVERITY OF
THEIR ILLNESS SO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION.
I NAME IS MIA BAXTER I'M WITH
JEDI EXTRACTS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I'M GREGG CRIMINALLY OF A
CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLYMAN
GRAYSON'S.
I'M ALSO WITH THE JEDI I'M A
PATIENT A CANCER PATIENT WITH
THE JEDI EXTRACTS OF SHOW FOR
PROGRAM -- AND I'M WITH THE CAL
NORMAL OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSING THIS
BILL.
ELLEN COMP WITH CALIFORNIA
NORMAL PROP SIXTY FOUR HAD AMONG
ITS STATED PURPOSE IS TO ALLOW
MEDICAL ACCESS AS WELL AS
PERSONAL RIGHTS WE THINK THIS IS
OUTSIDE A LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ABILITY TO REGULATE LAND USE.
DO NOT THINK THAT ALLOWING
PATIENTS TO GROW THEIR OWN SIX
PLANT IS GOING TO WORK BECAUSE
LOCALS ARE REALLY CRACKING DOWN
ON THAT POSSIBILITY ESPECIALLY
FOR DISABLED PATIENTS THANKS.
MY NAME IS WAS THE THIRTIETH.
I AM A NAVY VETERAN AND I'M ALSO
CHAPTER PRESIDENT FOR THE WE FOR
YOUR PROJECT IN SAN JOSE.
I'M I HAVE.
AT LEAST EIGHTY FIVE VETERAN
PATIENTS ON MY ROSTER WHO ARE
USED CANNABIS IS MEDICINE AND
DESERVE ACCESS TO CLEAN MEDICINE
THAT CAN BE DELIVERED TO THEM.
ON DAYS WHEN THEY CAN'T LEAVE
THEIR HOME -- MANY VETERANS HAVE
PTSD THAT KEEPS THEM FROM
LEAVING THEIR HOME OR GIVE THEM
A CORE PHOBIA FROM ANYTHING THAT
MAY BE ON THE STREETS.
IF YOU TAKE DELIVERY SERVICE
AWAY FROM THEM YOU TAKE AWAY
THEIR ACCESS THANK YOU -- GOOD
MORNING AT ONE LOMBARD WE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY NAME IS ARE COMING ONLY I AM
A DISABLED COMBAT VETERAN I AM A
MEMBER OF THE WEEK FOR WARRIORS
PROJECT I'M ALSO THE COMMANDER
VETERANS OF FOREIGN WARS POST
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITHOUT
SAFE ACCESS TO CANNABIS.
I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THE WORK THAT I DO TO HELP OTHER
VETERANS.
GET OUT OF HOMELESSNESS SAVE
THEIR LIVES BECAUSE THIS
MEDICINE REALLY DOES SAVE LIVES.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE PHONE WITH
BETTER IS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUICIDAL THAT HAVE BEEN AT THE
AGE OF THEIR ROPE AND I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET THROUGH THAT
WITHOUT IT BEING TRIGGERING FOR
ME.
BECAUSE I HAVE HAD SAFE ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CANNABIS. TWENTY TWO
VETERANS A DAY COMMITS SUICIDE
THAT'S A REALITY FOR ME THAT IS
WHAT I LIVE WITH TWENTY TWO OF
MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS COMMIT
SUICIDE EVERY DAY.
PLEASE.
THINK ABOUT THAT WHEN YOUR BODY
ON THIS BILL THESE ARE REAL.
PEOPLE THAT ARE DYING EVERY DAY
THANK YOU.
HI CAITLYN IDEA WITH EASE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HI FRANKLY CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS TONY BOWLS I AM
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHAIR OF
AMERICANS FOR SAFE ACCESS THE
NATION'S LARGEST CANNABIS
PATIENT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE 60% OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS IN NEED OF CANNABIS
THIS SO LIVE MORE THAN AN HOUR
AWAY FROM A DISPENSARY.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
BILL AND PROTECT SAFE ACCESS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JOANNA CEDAR FROM
CANNOT CRAFT I'M ALSO A MEDICAL
PATIENT AND A CREDENTIALED
HEALTH EDUCATION TEACHER.
AND WE OPPOSE AYE OPPOSED THE
BILL PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NEIL YARBOROUGH Là.
MARINE CORPS COMBAT THAT THAT
FOUGHT FOR EVERYONE IN YOUR
GUISES FREEDOMS RIGHT HERE AND
ALL YOUR GALS DO THAT ARE IN
THIS ROOM.
I WAS ON TONS OF V. EIGHT
MINUTES UNTIL THEY SAID I COULD
USE CANNABIS. TO GET BETTER.
EITHER ONE OF THOSE COUNTIES
THAT BAND THAT CANNABIS AND NOW
I CAN'T EVEN GROW IT.
AND NOW YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU
CAN'T EVEN GET IT DELIVERED TO
ME [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS BEFORE YOU VOTE.
OKAY BECAUSE YOU'RE DEALING WITH
PEOPLE'S LIVES HERE.
HELLO I'M AMANDA SHAME I AM A
DRIVER FOR INDIGO RIVER AND I
OPPOSE THIS.
HELLO MY NAME IS VALERIE
WILLIAMS I AM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IRVINE PARTNERSHIP
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL --
BECAUSE IT WILL HURT SMALL
BUSINESSES BY IMPOSING MORE
TAXES FEES AND REGULATIONS ALSO
CALIFORNIA HAS A RACIALIZED
HISTORY OF ENFORCEMENT.
AND THIS REQUIRES A STRATEGY TO
ENCOURAGE THE UNDERGROUND
BUSINESSES TO ENTER A LEGAL
MARKET THAT IS SAFE IN SUPPORT
OF AN EQUITABLE.
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS --
SHOULD BE ASSURED BY STATE
POLICYMAKERS OF THAT.
THE OF THAT YOUR INTENTIONS ARE --
NEEDED AND AND AT THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GABRIEL
GUARDING I'M AN EMPLOYEE OF
INDIGO RIVER I DRIVE FOR THEM.
IT IS MY LIVELIHOOD IF WE CAN'T
DO OUR DELIVERIES OF THE GETS
TAKEN AWAY FROM US I LOSE MY JOB.
SO I REALLY OPPOSES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMMA WAY LESS I AM A
RETIRED NURSE.
I WORK FOR INDIGO RIVER AS A
SUPPLEMENT TO MY SOCIAL SECURITY
RETIREMENT.
AS A CARE GIVER I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS TANYA
ARMSTRONG AND I WERE FOR INDICA
RIVER ALSO AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
KELLY AND I'M AN EMPLOYEE OF
INDIGO RIVER I'M A DELIVERY
DRIVER.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
DON'T KEEP US FROM HELPING
PEOPLE IN NEED.
HI MY NAME IS THIS IS ISLA I'M A
DRIVER FOR IN THE GO RIVER AND
APPLES IS BUILT.
I'M A REDUCTION I'M AND DRIVER
FOR INDIGO RIVER.
I THAT CUSTOMERS LATCH ON ME
ANSWER CRIME BECAUSE THEY'VE
CANCER AND ARE UNABLE TO LEAVE
THEIR HOUSE AND THEY THANK ME
FOR DELIVERING YOUR MEDICATION.
AND I WOULD AYE AYE OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE I WOULD HATE TO SEE
THESE PEOPLE WITHOUT THEIR
MEDICATION THAT IS NOT OPIOID
DERIVED OR SOMETHING THAT'S EVEN
LOWER QUALITY.
FROM THE BLACK MARKET THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW WHEATLEY --
TEN AFTER ARMY COMBAT VETERAN
I'VE TO GENETIC BRAIN INJURIES I
WAS ON THIRTY PILLS A DAY UNTIL
I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA WHERE I
WAS ABLE TO GET.
CANNABIS TO HELP ME I AM NOW ON
ONLY FIVE PILLS A DAY SO I
DEFINITELY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BENJAMIN
EVERITT -- FOURTEEN YEAR COMBAT
VETERAN ARMY.
AND I POST THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT HURTS VETERANS.
MY NAME IS PAUL I'M SEMI U. S.
ARMY VETERAN A DISPLAY.
TO REALLY CRAZY TO NOTICE THE
PUBLIC TURN OUT IN OPPOSITION --
IS SPECIFICALLY FROM THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
LEGAL PATIENTS -- AND THEN SAFE
ACCESSES ARCHY CONCERN.
I OPPOSE THIS WILL.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE TEAMSTERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SABRINA FENDER BERKELEY PATIENTS
GROUP IN OPPOSITION -- PROP TWO
FIFTEEN GUARANTEED SAFE
AFFORDABLE ACCESS WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT PROHIBITION DOESN'T
WORK THAT'S THE POINT OF SIXTY
FOUR AND PEOPLE WHO RENT AREN'T
ALLOWED TO GROW SO THAT DEFEATS
THE PURPOSE.
MY NAME'S CHRIS MOORE SAID IN A
VIETNAM VET CANCER SURVIVOR.
AND I LIKE TO GET A KNOWING THIS
PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LOUIS ARGENIS ON THE
LEADERSHIP OF STOCKTON WOULD
FORCE AFTER.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO OPPOSE THIS
SO I CAN PLEASE HELP MY VETERANS
ULSTER THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBIN BEVERAGE ON THE
U. S. ARMY VETERAN AND I'M ALSO
A MILITARY SEXUAL TRAUMA
SURVIVOR.
WITHOUT CANNABIS BEING DELIVERED
TO MY HOME I WOULD HAVE ACCESS
IT'S A GOOD THING I'M HERE TODAY
AND THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE THEY
CANNABIS I SPEND MOST OF MY TIME
INSIDE.
MY NAME'S WILLIAM CRANE -- IN
THIS ABLE NAVY VETERAN I LIVE IN
RANCHO CORDOVA.
IF YOU GUYS PASS THIS BILL I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK ON OPIATES
AND I'LL PROBABLY KILL MYSELF.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE I WAS OUT
FOUR YEARS AGO.
SO PLEASE DON'T PASS THIS BILL I
DON'T WANT TO DIE.
I AM JUST WILLOWS I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
I WORK FOR YOU TO GO RIVERS WELL
AS A DELIVERY DRIVER -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT CITIES WHEN I
HAVE A LITTLE MORE CONTROL OVER
YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN THEIR CITY
BUT IS IN IF THIS BILL PASSES
THEN.
THAT'LL GIVE ANOTHER RISE TO THE
BLACK MARKET AND I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE.
ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT THE CITY'S
TELLING THEM WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT PUT IN THROUGH THE BODIES
THANK YOU.
HELLO DEAL SHE FOR DISABLED NAVY
VETERAN ATTORNEY FOR WHEAT FOR
WORKERS PROJECT AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MAYA PORTS HE
HAD TO MAKE A MAY U. S. ARMY
VETERAN OF O. I. F. O. EF.
WITH COMBAT IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE I CAME BACK
SEVERELY DISABLED AND IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE COMPASSIONATE
BILL IN CALIFORNIA FOR CANNABIS
I WOULDN'T BE ALIVE TODAY.
THANK YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YOU'RE ON THE FENCE AND
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS COALITION IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL ANGLER
I WORK WITH IN THE RIVER IN
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO KRISTIN NUMBERS ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
HI I'M ROBERT BROWN HERE WITH
KHALIFA AND I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS SEAN AND I AM A
KHALIFA EMPLOYEE AND I AM A
DRIVER THROUGH THE EASE PLATFORM.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL -- JUST ONCE
THEY WERE REAL FAST I DEFINITELY
BELIEVE.
THAT THIS INDUSTRY SPORTS GREAT
JOBS HAS FIVE YEARS I WAS
DRIVING FOR LIFT AND UBER AND
TAKE OUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE A
DRIVER FOR AIDS.
LEGAL COMPANY AND I JUST SAY
IT'S IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
IT'S SO MUCH BETTER THAN DRIVE
IN FOR THOSE OTHER áP COMPANIES.
SO I OPPOSE THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CAMERON ANDERSON
I'M A UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
COMBAT VETERAN AND I'M ALSO AN
EMPLOYEE OF CLEVELAND AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL SUMMER.
FIVE HI AM CHRISTY EVERADO I
WORK FOR CLEVELAND I OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF CMG COOLEY
THAN STRONG OPPOSITION IS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMYLIN MATHIS MAY
HAVE BEAUTY W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN OPPOSITION.
JULIAN COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA'S
MANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
JANA GETS IN AND OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL.
I MADE A CARRILLO ADVOCATE THIS
IS AGAINST MEDICAL FREEDOM I
POSSESS THE CURRENT COOPER
PENGUIN IN HAND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ERIC SKLAR FROM TAKE
ONLY A CALIFORNIA NAPA VALLEY TO
ME AS MY COMPANY I'M ALSO A
FORMER COUNCILMEMBER PLANNING
COMMISSIONER VICE MAYOR INSANELY
HOPEFULLY FOR LOCAL CONTROL BUT
THIS IS ABOUT.
A LEGAL BUSINESSES LICENSED BY
THE STATE USING PUBLIC ROADS TO
DELIVER TELL ADULTS A LEGAL
PRODUCT SO I WILL WELL
INTENTIONED I THINK THIS DEFEATS
THE IDEA OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
LOCAL CONTROLLED ABOUT LAND USE
NOT ABOUT PUBLIC ROADS THANK YOU.
MAX BECAUSE ON HAVE A FLOW KALRA
SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS ALLIANCE
OPERATION EVEN BACK AND FIT CVD
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU CAN
UP IN CAMPUS DELIVERY YOU CAN
ONLY PAN LEGALS LIVER SERVICES.
AND A VOTE FOR THIS BILL IS A
VOTE FOR THE ILLICIT MARKET
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME SHOWN KERN OUR
PRESIDENT WE FOR YEARS PROJECT --
I DON'T THINK I NEED TO SAY MUCH
MORE THAN ONE EXCEPTIONAL TAKE
WAS SOME PEOPLE AS WE DO OPPOSED
THE CRACK CRACK DOWN PART OF
THIS BILL MORE THAN ANYTHING --
IN PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A FUNCTIONING MARKET.
PROP SIXTY FOUR HASN'T WORKED
OUT LIKE WE ALL THOUGHT ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSION
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS AGO.
WHEN A CRISIS AND ACCESS CRISIS
IN INTO YOU GIVE US A CHOICE TO
CHOOSE THE LEGAL MARKET YOU CAN
NOT CRACKED DOWN ON US FOR
CHOOSING?
AND USING THE MORAL DECISION
WHICH IS MEDICAID IN OURSELVES
OUR FAMILY.
IS MUCH HAPPIER THANK YOU.
GERMAN MEMBERS GEORGE MILLER
BAFFLE WITH MAPS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME AGAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AT THIS TIME TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY SING THAT THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY ARE THE NOW
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
WILL BEGIN BY.
GOING OFF WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS JUST --
NOT THAT I THINK I NEED
ANNOUNCES BUT I HAVE -- ABSOLUTE
THEM IMMENSE RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR.
AND FOR THE INTENT THAT HE HAS
ON THE BILL HOWEVER I WON'T BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT TODAY -- THIS
BILL. FOR THE FOR THE SIMPLE
REASON THAT -- DELIVERY IS A WAY
OF ACCESS NGUYEN -- THE BANNING
OF OF THE PRODUCT AS FAR AS
GROWTH I I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
A PROVISION FOR MEDICAL GROWTH
TO BE ABLE -- TO FOR FOR FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO GROW FOR MEDICAL
PURPOSES HOWEVER AS WAS STATED
IN PRIOR TESTIMONY -- RENTERS
MAY NOT BE IN THAT POSITION TO
BE ABLE -- I AND TO TO
PERSONALIZE THIS A LITTLE BIT
THERE'S NO DOUBT -- THAT MY
MOTHER WOULD BE ALIVE TODAY HAD
SHE JUST HAD ACCESS.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT -- OPIATES
PRETTY MUCH HARDEN HER BODY UP
FROM HEAD TO TOE.
SO WITH THAT ACCESS FOR ME IS
THE THE BIGGEST BIGGEST ISSUE
EVEN THOUGH I DO SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL I FELT LIKE THE DELIVERY
WAS A WAS THE MEDIUM THAT THAT
ACCESS.
NGUYEN A LOCAL JURISDICTION
WOULD PAN -- OTHER PARTS OF IT
WHETHER IT BE STOREFRONTS
MANUFACTURES OR WHATEVER SO -- I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT AND WANT
TO HELP TRY TO PRESERVE LOCAL
CONTROL IN EVERY WAY I CAN --
BUT AT THE SAME TIME NOT HINDER --
ACCESS AND I UNDERSTAND THAT IF
YOU WILL I DO UNDERSTAND THAT IT
IS THE HOPE OF THE AUTHOR
RELEASED I DO MAYBE YOU CAN HELP
ME -- THAT LOCAL AGENCIES WOULD
THEN WITH LOCAL CONTROL BE ABLE
TO OPEN UP THEIR THEIR ABILITY
TO ACCOMMODATE ACCESS.
BUT I DON'T FORESEE THAT
HAPPENING IN THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE AS YOU TESTIFIED IT'S A
NEW WANTS THAT TAKES TIME.
SO I WANT TO KEEP ACCESS OPEN.
IT WAS IT WAS AT A FORM OF OF A
QUESTION MISTER GRAYSON OR DO
YOU KNOW IT WAS.
OKAY WAS ALONG JUST FINE AND
AGAIN IT I JUST WANT TO GET
CLARIFICATION AND THE AUTHOR CAN
ADDRESS WHICHEVER COMES THAT YOU
WISH LIGHTNING IS CLOSE YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK -- I THINK -- THE
POINT THAT I BROUGHT UP ABOUT --
THE INTENT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IS IT IS IT YOUR
INTENT THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WOULD TAKE YOUR BILL AND USE IT
FOR LOCAL CONTROL TO ALLOW.
ACCESS -- TO MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
I WANT TO JUMP ON THAT ACTUALLY
ABSOLUTELY THAT WOULD BE MY
INTENT.
I THINK THE PROBLEM YOU HAVE IS
THE AS WE PASSED A BALLOT
PROPOSITION.
THIS SAYS THE LEGISLATURE CANNOT
CHANGE EXCEPT TO FURTHER ITS
INTENT.
THE INTENT EXPRESSED IN THE
BALLOT ARGUMENTS.
IS LOCAL CONTROL.
INDEED THE LA -- ANALYSIS SAYS.
A PERSON CAN GET DELIVERY FROM
THEIR LOCAL BUSINESS FROM THEIR
BUSINESS.
SO IT ACTUALLY THE BALLOT
ARGUMENT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR JULY
DELIVERY IT CUT THE PLACE I HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE BRICKS
AND MORTAR STORE.
AND GET DELIVERY.
SO BILLS THE PROPOSED A
DIFFERENT DELIVERY MODEL.
DON'T ALIGN WITH THE LANGUAGE OF
THE PROPOSITION.
DON'T LINE WITH THE
REPRESENTATION THE PUBLIC IN THE
BALLOT ARGUMENTS.
DON'T ALIGN WITH A JASON KENNEY
WAS TELLING PEOPLE MONTHS BEFORE
THE VOTE.
SO THIS FACT WHICH I HAD NO
PRIOR NOTICE OF THAT THE SERIES
OF NOW SUIT ON THIS ISSUE.
WHATEVER YOU THINK THE THE VIEWS
THE MERITS OF DELIVERY.
THERE NEEDS YOU NEED SOMEBODY.
TO TRY TO FIND A WAY TO
RECONCILE THESE VIEWS WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF PROP SIXTY FOUR AND
THE POLICY IN THIS AREA.
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY SUBMITTED
AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THIRTY BECAUSE IT IS
CLEARLY SUPPORTED LOCAL CONTROL.
BUT JUST AS CLEARLY SUPPORTING
MOVEMENT BY LOCALITIES TO GET
INTO THIS BUSINESS OF ALLOWING
IT.
AND THEN POLICING A PROGRAM.
IS THE PATH.
THAT I THINK YOU START WORKING
ON THINGS I WILL SAY.
I COME OUT OF CITIES
[inaudible]
BUT YEAH.
I ACTUALLY HAVE A STRONG
CONNECTION.
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES BECAUSE I
BECAME A COUNCIL MEMBER NO.
THREE ALL.
FOR I'VE GOT ACT WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND BIO NINE I WAS
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT STATEWIDE.
I JUST MOVED TO THE RANKS OF THE
LEAGUE.
TOP LEADER I DIDN'T END UP
TAKING THAT JOB BECAUSE I
STEPPED AWAY FOR THAT BECAUSE OF
THE NEW JOB FROM MY PERSONAL
POINT.
THAT DIDN'T FEELS COMPATIBLE.
BUT SO I ACTUALLY FEEL I HAVE
STRONG RELATIONS LEAGUE OF
CITIES.
I ALSO APPRECIATED PAUL SMITH
BEING HERE.
BECAUSE I REMEMBER SITTING IN
JIM WOODS OFFICE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW THIS WILL ALL IN FULL.
AND WAS IN THAT MEETING THAT I
EXPRESSED THE VIEW WHICH I I
BELIEVE IS THE PATH OUT OF THIS
DILEMMA.
WHICH IT CAN IT'S KIND OF A
FUNNY ANALOGY.
DECISIONAL MISTER SMITH IS GONNA
BE LIKE WORLD WAR TWO IN THE
PACIFIC.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE HEADWAY.
ON CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS.
AND OF OTHERS AREN'T THERE ON A
ONE THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE AS WE
MAKE HEADWAY THE PRADO HORRIBLE
SCHOOL.
DIMINISH IN PEOPLE'S MINDS WILL
PICK UP ON THE JURISDICTION.
I FEEL THAT IS THE WAY TO
RECONCILE.
THE LONG RUNNING POLICY THE
STATE'S SUPPORTING LOCAL CONTROL
THE MEDICAL MARIJUANA PROP.
SIXTY FOUR WHAT THE BALLOT
ARGUMENTS AFFIRMED WHAT THE LA
OR FIRM. TO AVOID LITIGATION ALI
WORK ON THAT THIS YEAR.
BUT I I THAT THE PROBLEM I THINK
YOU HAVE IS THAT YOU CANNOT PASS
A BILL THAT GOES CONTRARY TO THE
INTENT.
AND THE RECORDS PRETTY DARN
CLEAR.
AND TO BE PERFECTLY HONEST I'VE
AYE AYE PROBLEM INCLINED TO KIND
OF RIGHT OR NOT BAD AND PLACE IT
SOMEWHERE.
ESPECIALLY MY VIEW OF ALL OF
THIS IF.
IF I'M NOT AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE CONVERSATION
THE CONTEXT OF AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN THIRTY BUT I SORT OF
FEEL WERE AT A MOMENT LIKE WE
WERE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WHERE
THIS COMMITTEE.
BY A FIRM IN A GENERALIZED PATH.
AT THE FIRST POLICY HEARING IN A
TO HOUSE PROCESS AT LEAST THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
CONSORTIUM POINT OUT A DIRECTION
FOR SOME FURTHER WORK WHICH I
WOULD CERTAINLY UNDERTAKE.
I'M NOT LATE TO THE CONVERSATION.
I'VE BEEN IT'S IN THIS TOPIC FOR
A LONG LONG TIME.
AND TRY TO BE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION -- I I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
TAKE SOMETHING AWAY FROM PEOPLE
AFTER THEY YOU OF ALREADY
GRANTED THE ACCESS -- I THINK WE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF FOLKS OUT
THERE AND WE ALL HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH THE OPIOID
CRISIS -- THE SAFE AND LEGAL AT
A CANNABIS PROVIDES PEOPLE A
DIFFERENT OPTION -- AS AS A
VETERAN AND I WAS ALSO SOMEBODY
WHO COMES FROM LOCAL.
CITY GOVERNMENT -- I APPRECIATE
THAT WHEN WE PASS IT WAS ABOUT
BRICKS AND MORTAR AGAIN THIS IS
ABOUT DELIVERY -- SO I WON'T BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
BUT I APPRECIATE THE THE THE
HISTORY YOU PERCENT PROP.
SIXTY FOUR TALK ABOUT YOUR LOCAL
STORE AND GET IT DELIVERED FROM
IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YET YOU
KNOW I I'M NEW TO THAT BEING P.
COMMITTEE AND IS MY FIRST TIME
IN YOUR SEARCH TURNED THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THE SAME TIME.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND THE AND THE FOUR OTHERS IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I I
WORKED WITH YOU LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HERE AT SAKS CITY WE WERE WE
WERE THE ROBUST CITY.
THAT STEPPED UP AND LICENSE SO
MANY THESE FACILITIES AND THAT'S
ONE ONE OF MY CONCERNS I HAVE
FOUR ISSUES I CAN'T VOTE FOR
THIS BILL I WAS GONNA LET ME OUT
FOR ISSUES.
ONE IS THAT IS ACCESS.
SACRAMENTO HAS STEPPED UP.
IN SAN FRANCISCO HAS.
AND BUT ALL AROUND US ARE THESE
DESERT'S.
A PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET ACCESS
AND SO FRANKLY IT'S GREAT FOR
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE OUR READ OUR
TAX REVENUE FROM OUR SALES.
OUR THROUGH THE CHARTS.
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IS
LITERALLY KILLING IT AS FAR AS
BRINGING IN REVENUE.
FROM MARIJUANA FROM THE
MEDICINAL AND NOW FOR FROM FROM
LEGAL USE.
BUT FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE DRIVING.
TEN TWENTY THIRTY FORTY FIFTY
SIXTY HUNDRED MILES TO GO FROM
THEIR RESIDENCES TO SACRAMENTO.
IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM FAIR.
AND SOME OF THEM DON'T HAVE THE
ACCESS FOR TRANSPORTATION SO I
JUST DON'T THINK.
THAT MAKES SENSE -- THE TWO
ISSUES I THINK ARE MOST
IMPORTANT TO ME ARE FRANKLY ARE
THE THAT THE HOW DO YOU BALANCE
LOCAL CONTROL VERSES WILL THE
VOTERS.
SO I GET WE HAVE LOCAL CONTROL
BUT WE ALSO HAVE.
A BALLOT MEASURE ON A MAJOR
CONVERSATION WITH ELECTION OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY HAD SOME UNDERSTANDING
AS FAR AS WHAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO ACCESS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND SO.
YOU CAN HAVE A COMMUNITY WHERE
IT A CITY WHERE THE VOTERS SAID
70%.
YES WE WE WANT TO HAVE THIS
LEGALIZING ONE HAVE ACCESS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD GO.
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
AND THEN THE THE LAST THING IS
IS BY HAVING MORE JURISDICTIONS
SHUT IT DOWN.
THAT JUST MEANS FEWER DOLLARS --
FOR THANK YOU TAXES COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA.
FEW OPPORTUNE A REGULATE THIS
MARKET AND FURTHER PERPETUATES
THE LEGAL MARKET SO I'M NOT SURE
HOW THIS REALLY HELPS THESE
ISSUES WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS
AND CAL THE PROBLEM IS KEVIN
THAT.
PURSUANT TO THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION.
LOCAL IT ALLOWS LOW COVERS TO
BAN ON MEDICAL MARIJUANA
BUSINESSES.
SO SO THE ISSUE IS.
THIS POWER TO BAN IS WITHIN THE
EXPRESS.
UNDERSTAND THE VOTERS.
SO WHAT YOU REALLY NEED IS A
STRATEGY TO INDUCE COMPANIES GET
OFF A BIT.
WHICH IS THIS BILL BY A FIRM AND
THEY HAVE LOCAL CONTROL BUT GIVE
THEM AN INCENTIVE. TO MOVE OUT
OF THAT POSITION.
THE PROBLEM IS THE VOTERS.
AUTHORIZED THESE BANDS IT'S NOT
CONTRARY.
IT'S A LINE WITH.
AND SO YOU HAVE SORT OF A YOUR
YOUR YOU HAVE A LITTLE CONUNDRUM.
HOW DO YOU BACK UP?
WHEN THE VOTERS AUTHORIZED BANDS?
AND THEN THE BAND BECAME THE
EXPEDIENT WAY TO GET A LOCAL
POLICY OF PLACE TO RESERVE LOCAL
CONTROL.
YOU NEED A PATH TO ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION. TO JUST HAVE
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT BANDS ARE
NOT.
THE PRODUCTIVE LONG TERM ROUTE.
WE'VE INVESTED A RESEARCH AT UC
SAN DIEGO.
THE MEDICAL CANNABIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTE WHICH DOCUMENTS ITS
UTILITY FOR EPILEPSY.
AND OTHER PURPOSES WE HAVE A LOT
OF KNOWLEDGE OUT THERE.
AND WE HAVE [inaudible]
THOSE JURISDICTIONS WHICH OUR
DOCUMENT THAT YOU CAN THESE ARE
COMPATIBLE THEY DO NOT DESTROY
COMMITTEE QUALITY OF LIFE.
THERE'S REASONABLE PROCEDURES IN
PLACE THE LOCAL.
JOHN D'ARMES THE POLICE CAN
OPERATE COMPATIBLE IN CHECK ON
ENFORCEMENT ALL OF THIS IS.
IT'S KINDA WORKING HIS WAY OUT
ITS THIS EXAMPLE OF YOU GET YOUR
BE CHAD JURISDICTIONS.
AND THEN YOU.
EDUCATE OTHER JURISDICTIONS ON
EASE UP.
AND THIS MY APPROACH REFLEXIS
LONG TERM STRATEGY SUPPORT LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT INDUCE LONG TERM MOVED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FISCALLY SHALL WE ACCEPT THAT AS
YOUR CLOSE MISTER COURTS YES YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND SEEING THAT THAT WELL AS
YOUR CLOTHES AND NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
A MYSTICAL IN THE AND FOR
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
YOU WILL SEE A NUMBER OF BILLS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE ON WHITE
SPECTRUMS WITHIN THE ISSUE OF
CANNABIS.
WE HAVE THE BILL PRESENTED
BEFORE US AND WE ALSO HAVE A
BILL THAT WILL SEE AT OUR LAST
HEARING WITH RESPECT -- TO OF
FORCING CITIES TO APPROVE OF
DISPENSARIES WHERE IS THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT DELIVERY TO CITY
SO WIDE SPECTRUM OF YOURS ISSUES
THAT WE WILL BE TAKING A LOOK AT
IN ADDITION.
TO A BILL PROPOSAL TO LOWER THE
TAX.
TAXATION OF CANNABIS THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE WITH
RESPECT TO THE CANNABIS WORLD
THAT WE LIVE IN NOW OF THE ONLY
A YEAR AND FOUR MONTHS OR SO
INTO LEGALIZATION.
IS THIS WEIRD MARRIED OF VARIOUS
REGULATORY BODIES WHETHER IT BE
THE LEGISLATURE THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
HOW DO WE HAVE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO WHAT WE WANT TO DO
WITH RESPECT TO THE DIRECTION OF
THE REGULATED MARKET?
AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE TO
STAMP OUT THAT OF THE BLACK
MARKET.
WE SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
AUTHOR HERE BEFORE US HAS HAD AN
EXTENSIVE HISTORY WITH RESPECT
TO YOUR PERSONAL WORK IN THE
CANNABIS -- YOUR LEGACY WITH
RESPECT TO LOCAL CONTROL AS
YOU'VE ARTICULATED TO US YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND LEADERSHIP IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES.
AS WE KNOW YOU ARE EQUALLY
DEDICATED TO THAT OF LOCAL
CONTROL.
AT THE SAME TIME WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS ISSUE BEFORE US IS.
ONE ASPECT OF CANNABIS ON LOCAL
CONTROL -- THE CHALLENGE THAT
EXISTS AS BEEN ALREADY BEEN
ARTICULATED BY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- AND THE ISSUE OF
THE DISRUPTION. TO THAT OF WHERE
WE ARE HEADED IS OF PARTICULAR
CONSIDERATION.
HAVING SAID THAT -- I DID
INDICATE TO YOU MISTER COLLEY
THAT GIVEN YOUR EXTENSIVE LEGACY
IN HISTORY OF WORK ON THIS
ENDEAVOR IT DOES MERIT --
SUPPORT -- FROM IT TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION -- SO I AM
GOING TO VOTE I TODAY BUT AS
SHOULD THIS BILL MAKE IT OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN ITS CURRENT
FORM -- I WILL BE VOTING NO
GIVEN THE CURRENT CONTEXT OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENTED
BUT YOU HAVE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO IDENTIFYING THE KEY
COMPONENTS THAT WE STILL NEED TO
ADDRESS AGAIN.
IS THIS IS THE FIRST POLICY
HEARING OF THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
AND WITH THAT THAT'S WHY I AM
GOING TO BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS -- BUT HAVING SAID THAT
ALSO HAVE THE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATIONS -- THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED.
HAVING SAID THAT AND I WOULD
JUST AFFIRM THAT THAT IS MY
REPRESENTATION.
YES SO THAT'S ON THE RECORD YES
AND AGAIN.
MY VOTE IS TO ARTICULATE THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE
CONVERSATION BUT AGAIN THE
HESITATION ON THE MOVING PIECES
THAT WE'VE ALREADY HAD -- BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE SO HAVING SAID
THAT IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL.
SECOND.
HEY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY LOW.
WELL I BROKE BLOOM.
WELL NO JOHN.
GEN NO CHILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
EGGMAN EGGMAN NOW FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING HOLDEN
[inaudible]
IRWIN.
AROUND AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY NOW
MEDINA.
AGAIN I OF A MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
WHAT?
THE BOAT IS A FORTY FOUR WILL
PLACE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR COOLEY.
MEMBERS -- WE'LL WE HAVE A JUST
THREE REMAINING ITEMS BEFORE US --
I WILL NOTE THAT THIS HAS A
SUPPORT.
ON BOTH SIDES THE ALPHA THE
REMAINING THREE BILLS THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US.
AND SO -- ALL ASK MISTER.
CHEN TO PRESENTED -- BEHALF OF
MISS KOREA.
AND AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS A A
SUPPORT SUPPORT AND THAT THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION BY MISTER MEDINA
SECOND BY MISTER MCCARTY.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PRESSURE TIME MY PRESENTING AB
SIXTY WITH YOU ON BEHALF OF US
LIMóN CREEL WHICH SEEKS TO
PROTECT.
PATIENT ACCESS AND BETTER
UTILIZED CALIFORNIA'S PHYSICIANS
AT WORK FORCE -- AB SIXTY TWENTY
WILL FIX INCONSISTENCIES AND
LOTS MORE ACTIVE REFLECT THE
TRAINING AND EXPERTISE OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS.
AND TO IMPROVE PATIENT ACCESS --
WITHOUT AYE COMMENTS RIDE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO BY MISS
CARILLO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEN NONE ANYWHERE IT'S JUST IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
CAN YOU MEMBERS THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO MOTIONS DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI THE
I. BRO BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN AYE CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM DALY EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON?
GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA WITHIN AYE
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
TING WHAT.
THAT BILL HAS NINE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE PASSED THE GAVEL OVER TO
MCCARTY.
AND THIS AGAIN DOES ENJOY A TO
PASS RECOGNITION ON BOTH SIDES.
HE CAN'T HE'S GOTTA.
PLEASE PROCEED MEMBERS THIS IS
AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT WITH
RESPECT TO KERR'S I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MAIN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS MAKING ALL RIGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CONNIE
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE AMONG HIS
MOUTH WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHECK A CORPORATE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU OPPOSITION.
NO OPPOSITION COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SING ON WITH A MOTION A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW THOUGH
I BROKE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY LIKE MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA?
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING
WHAT [inaudible]
WHAT I?
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF YOU COULD
KINDLY CALL US AND WE HAVE ONE
REMAINING BILL -- TO BE
PRESENTED IN THAT'S ONE FROM OUR
OWN COMMITTEE MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN WHICH IS AB FIFTEEN
FORTY AGAIN THAT'S A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY WAITING FOR THE AUTHOR SO
IN THE MEANTIME -- WE WILL -- GO
IN ORDER BACK TO FOLLOW ORDERS
SO THIS IS NOW FOR MEMBERS.
TO ADD ON TO ADDITIONAL BILL SO
WE'LL START FULL FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB ONE
NINETY NINE BY CALDERON WE NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOTION SECOND TWENTY SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ONE NINE NINE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR JUDICIARY HELLO I KNOW I
BROKE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
AROUND AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
TING WHAT.
WHAT I?
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS AB THREE
SEVENTY BY MISTER VOEPEL.
AB THREE SEVENTY MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
BLOOM.
CHEN UP WHEN WHEN MY SON.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
HI FONG FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GLORIA GRAYSON [inaudible]
I HOLDEN.
MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
TING WHAT.
WHAT I?
THIS WAS ASSEMBLY BILL OF THREE
SEVENTY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO YES YES AND NO ANY OF THE
THE AUTHOR AS IT WOULD PRESENTED
WITH YOU COMMITTEE MEN'S.
THE BILL HAS -- FOURTEEN VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT.
EMILY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THEN MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
RECOGNITION IS TO PASS. TWENTY
SIX AB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN?
CHEN NOT VOTING JILL
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
OBERNOLTE TING.
SENATE YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WITH ONE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS THERE AND
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BUT I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
GLORIA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
TING. FIFTEEN THE BILL HAS IF
FIFTEEN VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB FIVE TWENTY BY LOW DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON.
DOLLY.
DALY AYE [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE TING [inaudible]
ALL.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE BOTH THE
BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB THIRTY THREE MOTIONS TO PASS
BLOOM.
I'M AYE CHAN.
CHAN I TO EGGMAN.
I MEAN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
TING WHAT.
WHAT I? FIFTEEN VOTES THAT BILL
IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE.
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
LIVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS AB EIGHT NINETY
BY DOCTOR WOULD THERE'S A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB NINETY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BUT I CHEN.
GEN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
TO FONG.
I'M NOT VOTING GLORIA
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
BY MULLIN AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES THE
BILL IS OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SOME OF BILL
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY BRO.
BROWN NOW BLOOM [inaudible]
HI JOE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING IN MY BELLY.
THE ONLY NOT EARNING
[inaudible]
FONG.
FONG AVERTING GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE TING.
WHAT?
WHAT I? TWELVE THE TO THE BILL
IS OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS FIVE ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY BY SOMEONE
LOCALLY THERE IS AND NON
RECOMMENDATION.
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY MOTIONS
DEPRESSED COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY BRO [inaudible]
WELL I TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW DOLLY.
DAHLE IN OFFERING.
GIPSON.
GIPSON UPLOADING GLORIA
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MULLIN. FIVE ONE NINE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I TING [inaudible]
WHAT?
WHEN NUMBER IN? SEVEN TO FIVE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA SKIP AND STILL WAIT
FOR UP THIS HOLDEN.
THERE'S A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
OF BOTH SIDES AL MISTER HOLDEN
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN FORTY PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT AS BRIEF AS YOU WISH
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT
STEALING TO WITH MUSICAL THERAPY
PROFESSION AND GIVING CLARITY
AND DEFINITION -- TO THE
POSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY NOT IN THAT
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER GEIGER MAY
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIAN AND
PRIVATE PRACTICE SOME ALSO THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN MUSIC THERAPY
ASSOCIATION WE ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL WE WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE.
AND THANK HOLDEN FOR THE FOR
AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS TERRA
MCCONNELL -- I AM THE OWNER OF
MCCONNELL MUSIC THERAPY SERVICES
WE SERVE PLASTER YELLOW
SACRAMENTO ELDORADO AND NEVADA
COUNTIES.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN ADDITIONAL
WIN ASSISTANCE SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME COMMITTEE SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
UP DID OPPOSITION YES
AUTHORIZATION I'M SORRY HEATHER
STALEY WITH ASKED ME TWENTY SIX
TWENTY WE REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED MUSIC THERAPIST.
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED BY THE STATE
IN THE DEPARTMENTS OF CALVET --
STATE HOSPITALS.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND SEE
YOU SEE OUR WE ARE PLEASED TO BE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL TO INCLUDE A PROTECTIVE
LANGUAGE. TO INSURE THAT THOSE
STATE WORKERS WHO WERE HIRED
ORIGINALLY UNDER THE STATE --
REQUIREMENTS AND QUALIFICATIONS
REMAIN IN THEIR POSITIONS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM
TO INCLUDE THAT PROTECTIVE
LANGUAGE HOWEVER AT THIS TIME WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT.
STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SCENE NINE COMMITTEE
SECTOR WHICH THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY MOTIONS TO PASS
LOW I KNOW I BRO WELL I BLOOM.
BUT I JOHN.
GEN I CHILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
I EGGMAN AND I FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
HI HELLO HI [inaudible]
IRWIN -- AND I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN I OBERNOLTE AROUND THE I
CHING.
TING I WOULDN WHAT I TWO I
NINETEEN TWO ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS IF YOU COULD
KINDLY ASK THE SERGEANTS TO CALL
REMAINING COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN PRESENT FOR ANY
BILLS -- ON VOTING I WILL CLOSE
THE COMMITTEE SHORTLY AND SO
WILL GO THROUGH -- ITEMS ALL
OVER AGAIN.
YES YES YES WILL GO THROUGH AYE
ITEMS ALL OVER AGAIN.
YES WE WILL START.
THE COMMISSION SAID THE MEMBERS
THIS IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THE SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO THERE'S A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
ABORTIONS DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
BRO.
HI JILL. TWO I COMING UP.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALI.
DALI AYE GIPSON.
IT'S AN AYE GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I OVERLOOKED OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE WHAT.
WOULD I NINETEEN TO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT MEMBERS WE WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS AND GO THROUGH FILE
ITEMS AGAIN.
AND BEGINNING WITH.
FOR A PROPOSED FOR JUST ONE
MONTH.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO A FILE ITEM.
NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE NINETY
NINE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB ONE NOT ONE NINE NINE
VERSIONS ACOSTA JUDICIARY BRO.
BRIAN CHILL TO AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HOLDEN ALTHOUGH I
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
TING AYE. EIGHTEEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
THREE SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB THREE SEVENTY MOTIONS YOU
PASS AS AMENDED COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH CHILL. TO AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLD AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
WHEN I?
TING TING AYE. NINETEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOMEONE MAKE
APRIL DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHILL
[inaudible]
CHIU AYE.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
TING.
TING AYE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
I AM NOW. TWELVE JUST READ THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS HERE IN TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ANY FOR FIFTY EIGHT TO PASS AS A
MANAGER PREPARATIONS CHILL. TO
AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I GLORIA [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING -- LARA
[inaudible]
GORE I TWENTY TWO ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BY LOW DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BASICALLY.
AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DIVEST OF OPERATIONS TRIO.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
TING.
TING AYE. NINETEEN DOES YOUR THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AB EIGHT THIRTY
THREE MOTIONS DAY PASSED JAIL.
SURE I GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLD AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE. TWENTY TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY BY DOCTOR
WOULD DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB EIGHT NINETY MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
JILL TWO I GLORIA. FOR I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I TING TING AYE. SIXTEEN
TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN BY SOME OF RUBIO DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
COMMITTEE IMMENSE.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY.
JILL TWO I GLORIA GLORIA AYE.
TING TING AYE.
HOLDEN HOLDEN OFFERING. FIFTEEN
TO TO THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY THERE IS A
NON RECOMMENDATION.
AB FIFTY THIRTY MOTIONS YOU
PASSED TO COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY GLORIA.
GLORIA NOW.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN UP EARNING [inaudible]
TANK.
TING TING NOW [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU NUMBERING. SEVEN TO SEVEN
THAT BILL FAILS TO A WILL
PROVIDE RECONSIDERATION.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY BY SOME MEMBER HOLDEN DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FIFTY FORTY MOTIONS YOU PASS
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE. TWENTY ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
SIXTEEN TWENTY BY SOME MEMBER
CREEL.
AB SIXTEEN TRYING TO MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS GLORIA
[inaudible]
GORE I TWENTY TWO ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MEMBERS ARE WE JUST FELL AFTER
FOR THE COMIC THE COMMUTER TRAIN
JUST ADD ON FOR GOODNESS SAKE
[inaudible]
COOL.
I DON'T KNOW
.
ANYTHING ELSE MEMBERS FOR A
ANYTHING ELSE HAVE NOT WE WILL.
OKAY WE ARE NOW RETURNED
[inaudible] ONE I FORGOT.
BUT IN THE OLD --
SO
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OTHER [inaudible]
RIGHT
BY THE